what exactly is crackhead work ethics so
did you see the black lives matter
donation slash lawsuit who's oppressing
you you have 10 million dollars man will
you call everything there's a flight
against you are you trying to put a
racial spell on it actual racism is Con
it gets to slip in because you don't
even recognize it anymore you see some
of the effect of uh there's somebody out
there with half your IQ who's
accomplishing 10x what you are because
they're not smart enough to doubt
themselves
I choose to make humor out of my life
and in that humor one of the things
that's just funny to me man are
crackheads I think I think they're like
vampires man all right guys bang bang
very excited about this uh I thought the
first place we could start is a
crackhead work ethic and I'm gonna tell
you a story before you explain why you
talk about it so much but I have a
brother I got four brothers but one of
them uh used to joke all the time and
say crackhead wakes up and uh they're
gonna eat today don't let them outwork
you and I came across one of your tweets
like two three four years ago whenever
it was and I was like holy [ __ ] you know
my brother and I see you talking about
this and then I've seen you talk about
over and over and over again so what
exactly is crackhead work ethics so you
know people first off people wonder
where like that comes from or why I talk
about that so much and and you gotta
like understand where I grew up like
like I'm a I'm a project of public
housing and if you don't know anything
about public housing you know there's
the
average cues Urban elements a little
gang violence a lot of drugs that kind
of thing right so so you know crackheads
like this is part of growing up man we
used to get babies out by a crackhead
like I've seen people smoking [ __ ] and
and doing other drugs and and I remember
one time as a youngster I didn't I
didn't understand why why my mom was
arguing with the woman that baby shot us
because I was like oh I just squirted
some water on the couch why is this a
big deal I was like three or four well
it turns out it was a syringe full of
heroin that's what it was it wasn't
water I didn't know that and like and my
mom's like why you have this around the
kid and the crackheads like why who's
gonna pay for this it's all freaked out
so that was the debate who's gonna pay
for it it was it was silly like I
remember asking my mom about this uh
probably a few years ago and just like
reminiscing and all and that was the the
issue you know the she was mad the the
attic was mad because you know that's
drugs and who's gonna pay for them my
mom said why is this stuff out to her
kid can even get to it or whatever so so
you see this stuff and you have to cope
with it and I always say you know you
can laugh a little or cry a lot right so
I I choose to make humor out of my life
and in that humor one of the things
that's just funny to me man are
crackheads and I think
I think I think they're like vampires
man like if you look at them you're like
there's a joke like you can't kill him
or you can't catch them and they're
they're super strong I mean the reality
is like whether they're strong or fast
or whatever A lot of it is driven by the
need to acquire this very addictive
substance and that's where that work
ethic comes from I mean sure we could
bottle that without
the without the need to get addicted to
something that'd be awesome
all right but but you know we can answer
and said I joke about it and and then
those jokes I'm trying to I'm I'm
imparting some wisdom because look if
you ever seen someone get clean
a lot of times
what what happens is
you hold just break an addiction instead
you replace it or dilute it with other
things and a lot of times you know these
these guys will pick up something
positive and whoa just run with it
because they're no longer they're
getting their fix from something that
has a that has a positive externality
you know associated with it as opposed
to getting their fixed you know from
from an addictive destructive substance
so that work ethic that gets channeled
into a lot of other things and that's
where the crackhead where I think ethic
comes from I have this theory about
people and this I think aligns very well
with it which is uh there's High
volatility and low volatility people and
I've talked a bunch of times on uh on
the show about uh as an investor when
you're investing in Founders you want
High volatility people either they're
going to build a multi-billion dollar
company or it's going to be a big you
know hole in the ground but you want it
to go big right guys like Adam Newman
people like why is he keep getting money
it's going big you just don't know which
direction right but like it's gonna be
big and so so that's in investing but in
the regular world you know outside of
investing there's High volatility and
low volatility people and what you're
describing is basically High volatility
people where there's an obsession uh uh
like almost personality trait where yes
the drug there's a a chemical component
to it where they get addicted to it and
they become obsessive and all this but
if they replace it with something else
that then becomes an obsession whether
it's a drug or or not uh that's a high
volatility person they can swing
drastically and then go like 100 miles
an hour towards that thing and it's
almost like the person themselves is
their point in the right direction it's
a positive point in the wrong direction
it could be catastrophic and yeah and
then the two things come to mind when
you say that right so first I I never
described it as high volatility and low
volatility the the phrasing I always use
but it's not in the context of of an
addictive personality just kind of how
you grew up and what you you you know
experienced as a youngster I call it a a
a ceiling the ceiling on the floor
concept right when you grow up in a a
safe environment when you grow up
nurtured with with without really
wanting for anything I'm not saying
you're spoiled it's just not destitute
your your mentality is to to maintain
that and to kind of Meet the
expectations of the status quo you grew
up in so your your floor is higher like
you like you're not it's really hard for
you to fall off you got to support
system around you you you more or less
understand how to work and do things and
be a constructive productive
contributing member to whatever group
you're part of your floor is higher but
your ceiling is lower you're not we
you're never going to take risks you're
not going to fly off and do something
crazy because those those moves are
highly volatile you know to start a
business right you know you could
succeed and be great you could also fail
and end up going on the welfare line and
if you've never been in that position
that is like devastating we don't do
well with loss at all so you're like I'm
going to avoid the loss but better than
avoiding the loss you know you avoid the
game the potential gain as well right
and then the other thing I thought about
when you were saying that is
you know I know some people
who who did hard drugs and didn't get
hooked
you know I know a guy that smoke crack
like two or three times and he was like
you know that's just not for me
now no one would look at that end of one
experiment and go told you it was a scam
crack's not addictive like now like no
one will react that way but what that
tells me well there are a lot of
different ways to interpret that based
on what we know now and you know how how
your environment and who you are shapes
whether you're going to get addicted to
certain things or not but one of the
other interpretations is like you know
what if
there are people who for whatever reason
they don't they don't take two things
like that and then drugs just happen to
be an easy example to to look at and
measure because we can measure the the
negative output or not negative output
negative outcomes you know okay well
you're you're in prison we can ask you
where your drugs should come into Chrome
we can see the drugs behind it you know
you you get into the system in one way
or the other and we can see the affected
drugs but what we don't see are the
people who have that same trait never
pick up something negative but never
excel in something positive either you
know they're they're the people who it's
like who the the balanced lifestyle
folks right there's there's that whole
thing like oh you know you want a little
balance and balance is cool balance is
great and there's a lot of benefit to it
but one of the things you don't get
typically when you have balance is you
don't get exceptionality you you get you
know there are two ways to be to have a
to have a b average right which is to be
B's and all subjects all right I have
like two way days on a bunch of these
you know and it's still not going to
quite work out but but you tend to not
be exceptional in any one or two areas
that it's going to gain you recognition
or or a disproportionately or
asymmetrically higher uh income
than if you do the right balance thing
and you don't uh right it's I don't like
saying right if you take the balance
safe approach to life one of these
beliefs I think that's changed a little
bit in business is uh it used to be go
find the well-rounded person go find the
person who went to a certain school got
the degrees got you know uh this skill
said they were in this club they did
this extracurricular activity they
worked at this job for five years you
know whatever now I see a lot more
people talking about no higher for the
exceptional skill so exactly what you're
talking about don't hire the the B
student across the board hire for the
person who is amazing at sales and
they're horrible at Finance right
because guess what when they join the
team they are not going to be running
the finance team right they're gonna be
running the same Steam and you need
someone who's actually at sales and is
to go higher for that but what it makes
me think a lot about is like in your
life most people are actually aspiring
to be the well-rounded person and it
always cracks me up like I'll talk to a
friend I'm like you know what have you
been doing
and they'll tell me some like crazy uh
uh hobby they picked up or something why
are you doing that like it basically
because I think I should
um I do enjoy doing it though not as
hard as sucks I'm like so are you doing
it because it's hard and it sucks like
okay you know I I see that path of
thinking but usually is no because I
think that I uh I should be doing this
and it provides some social signal or I
want to fit into a certain group or
whatever and I'm just like man what a
life that would suck to like live just
doing [ __ ] because you think other
people expect you to do it and and what
you're describing
you're describing a lot of people and
and probably even more than I I tend to
Cluster because to me I see it as a
normal distribution I see a lot of
traits and and even if that's not like
exactly it almost certainly isn't it's
useful and we can make some useful
predictions if I tell you that you know
the the average person is is you know
balanced and most people fall within one
vulnerable two standard deviations I
don't either so you know they're going
to be kinda good at many things and are
kind of bad at many things uh that
leaves this rare individual as it is
that gets it whether and and whether
they get it intentionally or
accidentally stumbled into it and had
some good experiences and some payback
and care but it uh it doesn't matter but
they get it the the rewards are just
they're so disproportionately uh higher
they don't scale linearly I wouldn't
even say oh truly exponentially if you
are if you are really good that's how
you like like boxing for example
uh if you really if you're if you're a
good enough boxer to get into the top 10
you're gonna make a lot more money than
a club fighter but not nearly as much
money as the guy who is fighting for the
title my definition one or two okay
but to get to one or two you gotta give
up a lot even again the top ten you got
to give up a lot I wrote an article
about this when I was you know people
always ask me why would I stop with the
record I had and and it's a complicated
answer or at least multi-faceted answer
which is why I wrote the essay but one
of the things I touched on was that
for me to get to the top ten with my
ability where I started my size that's a
huge opportunity cost is it worth it
right now I'm making it I'm now I'm
making a decision because I happen to
have uh other skills that have a a
payoff and and I made the trade off I
think it was an appropriate smart one to
focus on building my my writing career
my website and everything I do on the
internet and plays of that but a lot of
people don't have that trade-off so you
look at
do you look at the fighters or would you
choose Fighters because that's the
example but I think it scales in any
competitive domain or domain where there
is a I guess zero sum is probably a
better way to look at it and
the people who make it to the top are so
much further ahead of everyone else in
the middle but to get there you have to
be obsessed like like those like anyone
you see playing professional sports on
TV those are well-rounded individuals
but it's actually kind of a joke here in
America that we make these guys go to
college first at least in in the NFL the
NFL I think is the only uh sport where
there's not a direct from high school to
Pro pipeline I know there's one in
basketball I know there's one in
baseball and I'm pretty sure there's one
in hockey but not not in the NFL but but
it's it's a joke that we're like you got
to go through the NCAA and go to college
because because who are we kidding here
you're not making these guys very rarely
where you get the guy that's like like
uh Myron roll remember him yeah was like
a road scholar he was in like pre-med
and he's also a star on the football
field I'm trying to remember God's name
he played for the Ravens uh Johnny I
follow him on and on Twitter I think we
follow each other buddy he's got his
degree in math you know I remember
Courtney Brown who played for the uh for
the Browns he was in engineering he had
an engineering major at Penn State but
these guys are like
rare rare I mean like we can name them
because they're so rare right exactly we
don't even follow football that much at
least I don't know I follow well enough
to know that like when when someone
outstanding like that shows up because
that's not normal what is normal is
being so obsessed that you get to that
level and you don't do anything else I
don't like like no one cares if these
guys can even really read I mean I'm not
saying that's a good or bad thing I'm
just pointing out that sometimes you got
to give up but we can read the defense
that might be more important to your NFL
friends then you know read love and
peace a warm peace you know that's what
we're we're looking for yeah all right
Elon Musk when he was on SNL he's I
think he said it best he's like I'm
trying to get to Mars did you think I
was going to be normal all right like no
and then I remember seeing all these
articles uh a while ago my father
actually he pointed out uh I think it
was like there's an article readings
like Jeff Bezos does the dishes at home
and like drops the kids off at work I
was like [ __ ]
[ __ ] right and I get that people want to
present like a certain Viewpoint right
but it's like it's also different
between what it took to get to a certain
point and then what you do once you're
kind of at the peak right but but it's
just it's hard work right and goes back
to kind of this like crackhead work
ethic uh idea of like if you want to be
great at something you have to [ __ ]
work hard if you want to be the greatest
crack addicts that's ever a little pipe
in the hood you're not dead you're not
getting a job you know you know look
I've met functional addicts like nah
you're gonna you're gonna be out there
every day you're hitting the scrap yard
or something right now I I don't I don't
want anyone to hear this and go this
this [ __ ] is is promoting drug
you like no that's not the point you're
commenting though on something that is
very real which also a lot of people in
society don't see every day right never
then they don't there's a whole I think
about this a lot
and I'll just tell you a random story to
illustrate this before I go into the
detail I remember one day in my old
neighborhood before I moved it wasn't uh
where I lived as an adult it wasn't a
bad neighborhood it was just any uh it
was just in the city
and and I know enough
about the the drug game and how it works
I know enough to know that you're not
storing a massive amount of product and
not everyone that's in the business is
going to live in the area where the
stuff is sold in fact you know why would
they okay
an hour it was like midnight or
something and I was up and I just heard
oh it was like a rain of bullets for
like five minutes they pulled up on this
house and just just eliminated it drove
off doesn't make the news now I'm like
are we gonna hear anything about this
nope
and and I said to myself I know enough
about the area I'm in probably
something related to
uh to drug trade like because the you
know the way that was done that's not
you know or maybe rent but unlikely
where I live all right so that's why I
tell that story I tell the story to say
that most people are like
living in the world and they don't
realize there are levels beneath and
above them
and if you don't see anything else other
than what you know you assume that's all
there is and that that's a that's a
whole that sounds obvious
but we don't think about the implication
of that I can talk all day about
everything I've seen and I think this is
one of the the reasons people enjoy some
of the the writing I put out
on this topic because it's a world
they're never going to touch and that's
not a bad thing I tell you like you
don't want your kids to see this stuff
man like because for every one of me
survivor's bias is a real mm for man
every one of me you know there's there's
a thousand or or probably a lot more you
know in jail whatever so
I I can see this and comment on it and
then deliver it up and it's I would
imagine it's in Reverse when you talk to
people I call it I call it like uh
visiting the Matrix when you when you
step down into to deal with people who
have no idea how how one can make a
living the way you make your living they
look at you like you got super powers
man for for from a lifestyle perspective
you're dodging bullets okay
and then you step by leaving go back
with other people who are interacted and
you know you know from The Matrix and
there is a loved one they can't imagine
your level any more than they can
imagine my level most people are are
sandwiched right in the middle and it it
back to what we were saying at the
beginning
they don't ever go below that floor so
they don't know what's in the basement
but they ain't ever going to lead a
house forget going to the attic they
never leaving
they're stuck there when I was in
college uh I got pulled out to go uh to
Iraq I came back and uh there's two
stories that always immediately jumped
to mind uh about this idea of a kind of
understanding the people who are ahead
of you and the people who uh want to be
in your position right because that's
really what it ends up being is
everyone's looking up it's just there's
very few people who look up and there's
nobody else up right and it's like
there's like five people in the world uh
but the first was when I came back uh I
was a white dude with a shaved head who
all a bunch of these dudes on football
team knew was he went to Iraq
there was like four or five kids that
maybe six months after I've been back I
said something to one of them and he
didn't look like he saw like a ghost I'm
like what's up and he goes uh bro I was
never gonna talk to you he's like you
got shaved head you went to war like
[ __ ] that
right and so like this idea of I had an
experience in life that they couldn't ex
you know even comprehend by the way this
same kid went to a school uh I think was
in Ohio or something I remember him
telling me like dude we had clear
backpacks and walked through metal
detectors like all this and I was like
no I was at my high school right so like
okay like we both have these experiences
in life that we probably could learn
from each other but just we it's hard to
understand without actually going
through it and the second thing was uh
got paid some money uh while I was away
uh in the military and I came back and I
was a young kid uh no wife no girlfriend
no kids no responsibilities outside of
like survive in this college environment
which is basically a cakewalk compared
to where you know I just was and so uh
somebody uh who I admired had told me
about a foreign currency trading oh that
just sounds like a get rich
get rich real quick so I started doing
this and I remember I was sitting in
class and I never forget it I was in a a
Chinese economics class and I'll sit in
the back have my laptop up and I could
see everyone else everyone's taking
notes doing all you know what they're
supposed to be doing and I'm not like
not trading but I'm like looking at the
charts and everything
killing football team sit next to me and
uh I mean he kept like kind of looking
over at me what the [ __ ] is this guy
this guy's just as dumb as me right like
what's he doing with this and so when he
left he said yo pop let me ask you a
question like what was that I was
foreign currency stuff and he goes like
how does it work and I told him like
super high level right like there's
these things they move and if you pick
the right bet essentially uh you can
make some money and he's like ah he said
you just made some money I said yeah so
far and he's like how much a thousand
dollars and he literally looked at me
and he goes bro that's better than drugs
and it's not illegal he said it's not
illegal and so you know we started
talking to whatever he came from uh
Washington DC area not the best area in
the world or whatever but like to get
rich quick that was his experience was
people would go into drugs or just do
things that weren't go get a nine to
five job or whatever and so it it's
funny because like those are like very
kind of closed environment you're on a
college campus you know it's like weird
things that people don't interact with
on a daily basis but if you extrapolate
that out just the United States versus
other you know Societies in the world
that alone we don't think about how uh
fortunate we are to be in a country
where look you can go say some crazy
[ __ ] on the street and you're not going
to get abducted and killed yeah right
like you know if you go to the extreme
example like there are Societies in the
world where a woman cannot walk outside
without her face covered mm-hmm
like that's a pretty big [ __ ]
difference than what we have here in the
United States
and
and if you never
being aware of it is one thing right I I
think one of the best things about the
internet and social media there's a lot
of negative and people it's very easy to
point out to negative but I think one of
the best things about it is that it
really does allow you to interact with
albeit sometimes in a um rather
explosive manner other cultures but if
you're willing to learn you get to see a
lot about the world that you had no
concept about and you get like a
firsthand real-time experience and
conversation and perspective from people
on the ground there
20 years even 20 years ago that wasn't
really a thing ah but now it is okay
but
to go in to go and live it to experience
even even not to that extreme but to
just talk to people who are not American
who who live every day not caring or
knowing about the stuff you consider to
be important
that you consider really important
people have told you are important like
for example like like our politics and
politics everyone makes a big deal goes
oh you know it's about government in the
United States and you live here and you
have to care about this and you need to
be fraud up and this makes a big
difference you know and and because I
spend I wouldn't say like a lot but
certainly certainly more than the
average person uh time out of the
country I'm just like you know there's a
lot of other stuff going on this is this
is just one thing you know there's a
whole group of people who don't they
don't even get a chance to vote in our
lady because they're not they're not
citizens and I just I think about that a
lot that a lot of people
have their their world
and their world is important and in
their world they can decide whether they
want to interact with other worlds are
double down on on standing in the world
that they have in the world that they
know are what makes the most comfortable
and I think we'll choose the Comfort
option of course uh but but one way or
the other sooner or later you you get
you get introduced to something
different or whether you're prepared for
it or not it's a totally different story
one of the funniest things to me in the
world is that the United States taxes
illegal immigrants
hold on let's rewind here for a second
so we're worried about all this stuff
right but uh the United States basically
was built on the idea of no taxation
without representation and we got people
who get taxed but they don't have a say
you know what blows my mind and then
that same vein is you know when I was
considering
getting my wall and I considered I'm
still going to do it I'm just not going
to do it the way I had anticipated
because I just know more now all right
uh when I was gonna grab my my
citizenship in in Portugal
and I was just looking to learn about
all the things and our texts girl and I
was like you're telling me that if I
ever stop being an American I still
gotta pay taxes because I was in America
once that blew my heart I was like I was
like why would I ever get rid of my
citizenship dude like that I get rid of
that that's the worst of all worlds yeah
they um uh so some people have kind of
gotten to this now but uh uh you know
that if you were to renounce your
citizenship uh you get taxed that day on
all your assets right as if you died so
basically you know call 50 give or take
uh but you know why they do that
there's a guy who was actually a
co-founder of Facebook who he renounces
citizenship he I think moved to
Singapore uh a couple billion dollars
where the Facebook Stock and at the time
there was no rule wow so if you renounce
you're good right if you're a citizen no
matter where you live in the world
wherever your residency is you you pay
Uncle Sam but if you were announced then
then you're good now you don't have a
citizenship right and so it comes out a
question like how important or how
valuable is it but if you got billions
of dollars and they may you take on
Singapore which is like one of the one
of the passports and citizenships that
that is more
um that gives you more access yes than
an American so after this guy did this
they were like hey hold on a second here
we're not gonna let this fly so they
they implemented this Rule and so it's
always funny because you can look at a
lot of uh tax law and it's because
someone somewhere figured out some
loophole or did something and then
they're like okay let's close that let's
change this decided it was too much yeah
and then so now we gotta pay if he had
done it with 100 million no one would
care we did a couple billion they're
like let's close that one this is wow
yeah
the the other uh taxing that's pretty
interesting is uh I don't know if you've
heard of these uh opportunity zones so
opportunity zone is basically uh uh
under Trump they came up with a map
essentially and they went into cities
and they said uh this is a honestly a
bad area but just an area that has
received less investment and so taxes
can serve as a carrot or a stick so
let's go ahead and put an incentive in
place if you take capital and you
invested in the pre uh selected areas
and you hold it uh for 10 years right
there's a lot of nuance but basically if
you hold the investment for 10 years you
don't pay taxes
so if you make a long-term investment in
areas that we're telling you need
investment then we will give you
favorable tax treatment one of the guys
who helped push that through is Sean
Parker from uh from Facebook and ours
right and so you start realizing it's
like well how did that log in please
because some guys who were Rich were
like yo we got a great idea right let's
go and Pitch it and do all this stuff
and so when you start to realize that a
lot of laws and regulations and
legislation and all stuff is like
there's usually it traces back to one
individual was like I think something
should change and people either get on
board or they don't but like that's how
the rules get made yeah uh one of my
favorite quotes man is from The Wire and
he the detective goes you know if you
follow you follow drugs
you're going to get drug addicts and
drug dealers but if you follow the money
you don't know where the [ __ ] you're
gonna end up
it's true and I think about that that
that is what is the yrs 11 years old at
this point uh and I think about that
what a poignant observation uh about
everything
in in our world not just the lullaby
politics in particular too yeah it uh it
makes you think hard well one of the
things that's interesting about you is
uh you've said that you've had four
lives and I think a lot of people don't
think of their lives kind of in almost
chapters right but but uh I think we're
unique in that
um
there's like almost like adolescence
right then there's this element of uh um
if you serve in the military in any
capacity there's like kind of a time box
around that time yeah it's weird it's
very very weird right and uh people who
have been in the military I think can
can uh understand that people who
haven't they'll be like what do you mean
like you you know whatever nah it's just
like that's a time in your life and then
there's these other chapters your four
chapters I think couldn't be more
different it feels like right and you've
really kind of transitioned between this
do you ever think that you're all for
those people or do you just think of it
as I used to be this person and now I'm
like a new person
I am if if I'm going to like look at a
transition Point uh a real
differentiation between each life and
whatever life comes up I think it all
comes down to what my priorities were
and what my weaknesses uh were at the
time so you know kind of what what's
driving me and what is holding me back
and sometimes they're the same thing you
know like hiking my mid-20s uh my
priority was was pretty much you know
drinking and chasing girls imagine how
to hold you back from making progress I
look back at it now in my my late 30s
and I go wow of course it's obvious and
then I'm like well why am I having these
issues in my life well because that was
my priority but it was also my obstacle
but but I think it's very easy for me to
separate that out because there's
there's these clear blocks I mean
because of the people I was around and
the things I was doing and and the
feedback I was receiving and what I knew
and all that they look like different
worlds and they have different
experiences in each world but I am I'm a
product of everything that I've gone
through and learned from the lucky
breaks and the tough breaks product of
all of it you don't get to leave any of
that you know behind and thank goodness
because
if you don't if you don't learn from
your mistake you're gonna repeat them
the thing about getting older is that is
that uh what was the best way I I've put
this if you if you take care of a
problem early
you get a discount on it
we take care of it when it shows up
you're gonna pay MSRP paying sticker
price but if you delay it
you're gonna pay a tax
and you know tax and a penalty on it and
it might exceed your capacity to and
like like and I came up with that when I
was thinking about the drinking thing
yeah when you start drinking
um I I saw this crazy I can say I say
relatively late like 18 is relatively
late but but yeah that's when I started
but it was out of hand and it was
causing me to make just awful terrible
decisions right out of the gate you just
drink a lot right out the gate you know
and there's no half step in here we were
just talking about that there's anything
worth doing is worth overdoing right you
know and and unfortunately you know I've
never been able to be a moderate God
that's you know I actually had a lot of
people don't know this I've been
swimming now it'll be nine years since
December a lot of people don't know I
had another period of sobriety from
actually a year and a half I think I
care I can't even remember I I no it was
longer in a year and a half it was like
from 20 to 23 I didn't drink uh because
I don't I don't know the middle there's
no no middle ear why would I uh like it
cracks me up man I can watch my girl
she'll she'll open a bottle of wine
because she wants one she'll open a
bottle of wine pour a glass and drink
half that glass and forget it was there
and that bottle didn't sit there for
like three four months before she even
goes back to it I'm like what's wrong
with you we used to go through two three
at night when it was time to drink a
bottle of wine not us together because
she has been a great influence but uh
in general us as in the the drinking
Community two three uh night so there's
there's no middle there but but when I
look at that
that Tom my life that is a
it's an example of
a life that if I didn't get in front of
that problem I was gonna pay a big tax
on it and get close because you know
there's
when you get in front of your problems
and you you express real remorse and you
express the desire to change and you
stick with that change
people forgive a lot probably more than
they should right
because because you you really are
making an effort and you made the effort
and it shows you seriously I'm sure
nobody would take me took me seriously
when I when it was a month in a year and
a lot more people like hmm five years
and I was like okay this this dude is
real it's not just an act or whatever
but imagine if I uh you know you say
that and you go back and do it again and
every time it's like oh man I'm done
drinking I'm done being an [ __ ] and
you go back and you do it again like no
it means nothing it you know it means
nothing I always I always say if if I
had to go behind bars and stop drinking
I imagine that then no one cares if I
stop then it's then it's you know
Society made me stopping and I've done
some damage likely you just stop cold
turkey or stop I don't kind of weaned
yourself off um
uh it's funny man
I I went through these these phrases so
so in 2012 September 2012 I I was I had
moved back to Pittsburgh where I'm from
where I live now I was out in Los
Angeles for like two years because uh
because of something related to boxing
so moved back
and I would do these on and off things
man like like I tried to go I was like
I'm gonna go
one week without drinking and see how it
is and let's go 30 days without drink
and see how it is and get back on and go
hard and go the other way right uh and
then finally
and when I came back from from my basic
I did my basic and then I did my um AIT
my AIT was was 22 weeks down in Fort Lee
Virginia basically was in Fort Leonard
Wood did that together uh they let out I
think I got back like December 18th
something like that uh then went out and
drink crazy made a fool and got
somewhere and I didn't remember getting
there I didn't but I just knew I drove
but I was like yo this is this is mad
and I got a bunch of stuff from the line
I like cared about myself more as weird
as that goes and and then I was able to
finally like stop but I made like a
public not a public declaration but I
texted
my five closest friends and I was like
I'm just letting you guys know I think I
got a real issue uh I'm gonna stop I
understand if you guys don't want to
kick it anymore because I think a lot of
people who stop drinking worried about
that and rightfully so because if
they're not good friends like I've lost
friends I mean they didn't like cut me
out and be like we can't be friends but
they stop hanging out with me or two or
three years in when they were so I was
serious and my life was making progress
and moves and you know we shifted away
misery likes company oh is it and not
just misery that's only part of it but
but more than more than misery people
like feeling like a position they're in
a position of superiority that people do
not like when the status changes and it
changes because you moved it not because
they move they're not very happy about
that but like people can cope with them
falling off and you you know staying
there but when they stay still or I
think they're doing well and then you
make a change and you you LeapFrog them
it's a it's a different game entirely
but yeah we made those are we I made
those changes and then it was able to
stick and I was busy I had things that I
was wearing on with my fighting career I
was I was back in school uh what else is
going on I was driving through the
website
it's trying to be a decent boyfriend it
was Dawn doing well and it's work
because you're still here you know yeah
um 10 years later and that's something
else when you said that you were gonna
stop so uh the reason I'm so interested
in this is uh in January of 2021 on
January 1st uh the night before I got
hammered uh as I think most people do on
New Year's
um and all through 2020 like I've never
been a huge Drinker by like going out I
like partying doing all the stuff
especially you know in my 20s and stuff
and uh for whatever reason during the
pandemic uh I joked that like I kept the
liquor store in business down the street
in New York City right and I was just
getting one but I would go when I pour a
fat you know glass of wine I could not
do what your girlfriend was doing right
in terms of drink a little bit yeah
whatever because I was just just
drinking but it wasn't like uh uh I was
addicted it was almost at like a boredom
right because there was nothing to do
you're sitting inside five o'clock bam
all right let's get a get a glass of
wine and so I was just like man not
maybe as coherent as you would being
like have a problem as much as it was
like uh uh January dry January I've
never done that before that sounds cool
let's see how I feel if I just don't
drink and I started to take Health a
little bit more seriously sleep more you
know do all these different things
during the pandemic whatever because I
had time to kind of think about like you
know and after 30 days I actually felt
pot committed right because I was on the
street hot streak like I can't drink on
day 32 right because I I get 32 33
whatever and I haven't drank since and
so it's been a you know almost a year
and nine months or whatever but I don't
have the same I think uh sense of like
accomplishment maybe as you do in the
sense of you were like I have a problem
I gotta correct it and what I think
about a lot is like uh fortunately I
think most people probably are more in
my seat than in yours where they drink
but they don't think that they have a
problem they don't think it's like too
much yeah it's more so just like maybe I
should drink less right and it's less of
like a black and white like in some ways
the black and white of like have a
problem let me stop it's a lot easier
it's easier right yeah that gradient man
I I just don't do well with it and yes
and anything in my life I mean well I'm
sitting here right now I had my coffee
this morning that I made in the room
then the coffee that they brought me and
then I went I got I got to the studio a
little early and I'm saying let me walk
down and get a coffee at McDonald's I
got a coffee here the difference is
after three coffees I'm not slowing my
speech and being making an ass myself so
we can we can do that but that that
middle ground you know um
I think so so first of all on alcohol
I'm not like anti you know of all you're
leading the prohibition charge anything
like that you know we want to drink you
want to drink with that said I always
remind people
there's no health benefit to alcohol
right it is in the purest sense of the
word of poison it's one we've we handle
you know better than cyanide but like
it's still not like your body's gonna be
okay without it either even even our
sweets you know you one could argue you
need carbohydrates we're not arguing you
know you do but you know and the sugar
is just the carbohydrate and I bring
that up to say you know some people go
you don't need sweets either I'm like
okay you don't need sweets but the
things that sweets are made out of you
do need is where I go with that not the
case with alcohol so so it's it's this
this ground but it's not gonna like you
know a wine glass one here or there is
not going to kill you though there's a
great movie this sign of one of my
favorite movies one of the best ones
I've seen um called shock collar
and shock collar is about this this this
guy he's a
I think he's like some type of insurance
or Trader or something like that for
like a white collar dude and he goes out
with his wife and their friend and he
has like a few glasses of wine and gets
into a car accident and ends up doing it
because the guy I think I can't remember
the guy down everybody ends up doing
like a year and a half in jail but they
they sent him to like for real no [ __ ]
prison I think it was like it was like
Chino or San Quentin or something like
that and while he's inside he clicks up
with with the white gang and they ask
him to do something and he ends up he
ends up you know killing somebody in a
fight and get he gets seven years three
goals from one year to seven and it's
about his transformation from this guy
who is just a regular old like dude who
has a job and a family and all that
stuff to become a like a shot caller in
prison and and what I took away from
that movie though and I watched her this
I mean it's a great movie
um the lead actor is the guy who plays
Jamie Lannister I can never remember his
name
um but one of the the things I I took
away from it was like yo imagine going
out tour like it's not like he was drunk
and got into the accident it was just he
just happened to have a BAC when he he
did and that's how your life goes down
the [ __ ] is you had a few glasses I
won completely not not impaired
whatsoever but things just there's a
it's a coin flip I think about this this
I did a coin a lot well humans are
adaptable too right you could take a
human and put them in the insurance
business and they have some path and
depending on their personality the
environment like all these different
things they adapt and uh I I think of it
as like uh they're playing a role in the
movie right in the movie of Life of like
you ever like meet somebody and you're
like bro you Coulda done seven other
different things and you're here and you
got the suit and tie on but like you do
not want to be wearing that suit and tie
right now I got a good friend one day he
was actually my best friend growing up
when we were kids in the because I lived
in two projects uh I lived in anybody
who's from Pittsburgh they'll recognize
these names but I'm you know give them
because they're important uh from from
birth to eight years old I lived in the
Hill district projects up in Addison
Terrace then we moved to Northview
Heights and that's right when jobs 18
those are both projects but my friend
when I was a kid was this kid
um
very similar like with you know the
world's strange man we were good friends
birthday was a week before mine I don't
know if you're in astrology or anything
like that but no we we were really good
friends and then we split off we kind of
stayed in touch and then
I didn't hear from him for years and his
social media made it easy to get in
touch and he uh I reached out to him and
we connected and started talking and
life was good
and but the first time we met up we met
up at a bar he was kind of out of it
and then I didn't hear from him again
for like two years and then we we linked
to begin and he was like I want to
apologize for how I was the last time we
met I was uh he I think he was like
detoxing some because he was just about
to go to jail because he managed to
become
uh one of the most
uh well a powerful one of the most
powerful drug dealers in the City by
sheer luck on some sloppy police work
when they when they busted them
uh they busted them they were waiting to
catch him with all the drugs and the
house everything to put them away and
and I think they jumped the gun or
something this the story he told me and
they when they made the raid he was out
during The Re-Up and was able to to
discard the product so when they they
pinched him he didn't have a bunch of a
bunch of weight on them
and and when he was telling me because
one day he just sat down like and I
recorded it it was a cool conversation
he was telling me everything how he
moved from like weed to heroin and how
he started in high school selling and
everything out all worked and I'm
listening to this and I'm and I'm
watching him now because he's still got
the same personality and talents and
gifts and I'm just like man
you could have been anything but where
you ended up and and what was around you
you took your Acumen and your skills for
leading people and and you became the
plug and I was like wow that's crazy to
me just listening because now he's that
now he he's doing it's funny man how
this this stuff works it works now he's
doing uh substance abuse recovery work
helping people get off this stuff
and has also got his music on the side
he works and everything and I I think
it's really cool when you mention that
there there are people who could do
anything and I I think about my friend
in the same bro because we had stayed
together and I had moved and I'm coming
up with him I mean I have I naturally
for whatever reason we all come out a
little different I naturally have a
little more regard for the law a little
more fear of its consequences uh but I
could have ended up right next to him uh
and we we could have been running and
ruling things together but I don't I
don't know I'll never know because I I
went down a slightly different path and
that little Divergence made a big
difference it also makes me think of um
Jay-Z's got a new verse on uh DJ
khaled's album uh God did and in it he
basically uh is talking about the fact
that he's just sell drugs and now he's
like now they got weed in the stores
how crazy is that right like just 20 30
years ago you could get locked up you
could go to jail your entire life could
be derailed for something now you go to
the grocery store like the Apple Store
now man you go wild right and then you
look at the hypocrisy of
um you know all this talk around
Brittany Greiner uh being locked up in
Russia and now there's a lot of
um complexity sensitivities
geopolitical chess I mean there's a lot
going into it at the end of the day
we're talking about is a substance that
she's locked up for there and we've seen
multiple people come out and say wait a
minute we got people locked up for
similar [ __ ] here in the United States
right and so like is it hypocritical is
it no is the geopolitical sensitivity
that's playing into it like you start
thinking about it's like wait a minute
we got people in cages for plants you
know one of the things you know and and
I I keep meaning to like do a deep dive
on this because I have an intuition
based on what I've experienced growing
up that if that informs this opinion but
I haven't done a deep dive into the
numbers so I always like to to preface
that so people don't think I'm just
talking about my ass I don't know what
I'm talking about I am but it's based on
my experience and if the numbers
contradict me then the numbers are right
a lot of those people in jail for for
weed they're not in jail just sweet
um one of the things that happens when
you when you sell an illegal substance
is you don't you don't have the
protection of the law
so you have to compete
differently and a lot of those
competition methods well those are
problematic especially when we start
talking about big weight always just or
uh anything that is hard you know like
what they consider hard drugs you know
when you pretty much like you know the
Coke and it's derivatives to crack right
so that's like a different thing people
go you know we can debate the the
difference between the laws on coke and
crack but that's a different argument
because no one is going okay Coke's
legal we should be releasing the crack
dealers talking about the weed I don't
you know unless you ever move a big way
yeah you know then we start looking at
your your case and go should you be out
you should be not a not even a doubt
should we be removing stuff off people's
records absolutely that is a big problem
but I don't think there's there are
people who are doing big big senses like
football numbers in jail I don't think
they're the people doing anything like
that
because just for just for weed uh and
just and even just moving
I don't I don't remember what the uh the
the amount differences for distribution
versus uh you know consumption or
something like that but I I know that
you know I don't even think
even in even in the early 2000s where I
would be like mostly aware of and it
wasn't just like a thing in the
background noise in my life as I was
when a kid
I don't think anyone was really I mean
you had to get caught what up with a lot
of stuff but whatever enough tour they
were like where do you you're not
smoking this all on your own you know
for pretty much and that was that was
the big deal the one that always cracks
me up is when uh they arrest somebody
and they're like he had a lot of money
on them I'm like okay how much is a lot
right right and now he has 700 and I'm
like I know a lot of people got 700 in
their pocket when they're walking around
right I also know a lot of people who
don't have 700 in their pocket but like
you know whatever their the amount is
but then there's the people who are like
well we caught them he had 75 000.
come on what are you doing with that
yeah so that's why I think the other
piece that is fascinating about this is
um there's a book and I mentioned a
couple times now uh on the show because
uh is less about what's in the book as
much as how the book came together but
it's written by Robert Greene the guy
who wrote 40 laws power human nature
yeah and 50 Cent yeah
yeah
so first thing is it looks like the
Bible
they got it all they got the gold Pages
they got the whole thing right but
what's fascinating about that book is
Robert Greene is writing the way that
he's always written in a a very eloquent
articulate uh kind of uh theoretical
sense and then he
juxtap poses it to 50 cents life and
what you realize is like 50 Cent and his
lived experience is very similar to what
Robert Greene is talking about they just
use completely different language and
they had never had any clue that the two
of them existed until Robert wrote a
book and 50 Cent reached out to him and
all stuff but it's like man that tells
you a lot about Society right there
human nature is is
is the same you know I was just I was
just I made a tweet about this and
someone commented something interesting
that I agree and he I the the Tweet was
about you know I don't think that people
need to get their ass kicked for
disrespecting people but I but I do
think you need to be aware that there's
a penalty for disrespect and usually the
turn you know that that penalty is
enough to deter people from acting like
[ __ ] okay and and that's like the
whole I did you know Mike Tyson and said
like you know people have gotten way too
comfortable with disrespecting people
from behind social media because no one
thinks they're gonna get punched in the
face and look I'm not a pro violence guy
in fact I'm probably probably the most
peaceful fighter you ever gonna meet but
people who know how to conduct violence
are pretty much pacifist until it's time
to because I know how bad it can get and
how quickly right with that said
somebody said something real interesting
and I was like yeah that makes sense and
he goes you know he goes a lot of a lot
of of the societies were civilized
because men got together and were like
okay
if we make these mistakes we're going to
kill each other and that's not good for
anybody so let's come up with a set of
rules and to make it real clear instead
of conduct uh expectations for conduct
so it's very clear when someone's being
disrespectful and what they expect for
that confrontation right which was
pretty much eliminated that's why I hate
passive aggression I mean I really think
it's a weak thing to do because with
past progression tries to do it tries to
get the benefit of a conflict without
without the without paying the price for
it you know it tries to
they try to make you know get jab man or
get something you know snarky or
whatever and but but you do it in such a
way to where it's not obvious that
you're doing it or try to so when
somebody freaks out you you maintain
plausible deniability well you know in a
in a um
depending on your perspective more
affirmative or more advanced Society you
wouldn't be able to do that you have to
speak clearly and make your point
otherwise you just get ignored or you
don't have one and if you make a point
and it is in disagreement with someone
else's you gotta Express that in a
certain way otherwise you're inviting
trouble there's certain things you just
don't do those and fight trouble you
know so I think about that that a lot
the wording uh changes because because
we all use a different language and a
different vernacular you know our
lexicon is filled with different words
and things like that to describe the
same thing that we're observing and
we're all observing human nature we just
come up with different words for it so
you know Robert Green and his education
and his writing and 50 Cent with his
little experience they both have seen
the same thing and have different words
to describe it but it overlays perfectly
and then and then because it's from two
different perspectives you create it's
not one plus one equals two it's like
one plus one equals seven yeah and you
can even deeper uh and wider perspective
on these things the uh that book
specifically talks about fear and one of
the things that I've seen you say uh
which I just cracked me up and I was
like damn that is so true is you said
some of the effect of uh there's
somebody out there with half your IQ
who's accomplishing 10x what you are
because they're not smart enough to
doubt themselves which is just like yes
like talk a little bit more about why
did you think that was so uh such an
important point this episode is brought
to you by eight sleep good sleep is a
game changer and the eight sleep pod is
the best sleep machine I sleep on it
every single night a great night of
sleep allows you to be healthier be more
arrested and have more energy throughout
the day and on the brand new eight sleep
pod 3 you can sleep as cold as 55
degrees Fahrenheit or as hot as 110
degrees Fahrenheit that's the secret of
thermoregulation better sleep better
energy get yourself in each sleep you
can go to eatsleep.com today to go ahead
and get 150 off your order eatsleep.com
pump not only do I sleep on it every
night it literally changed my life and I
begged the founders to let me invest in
the company eightsleep.com go get
yourself an eight sleep pod and get a
better night of sleep because you get a
lot of people who everything is planning
planning planning planning planning
planning planning planning planning
planning
but the execution
because the execution is where you get
to find out is it a good idea now that's
for you face rejection I'm working with
a kid right now
uh he
has been training fighting he's been in
the gym going to going like a royal main
boxing for four years how many fights
you think this guy got no fights and I'm
like what are you doing like like do you
do you want to fight or do you want to
just say you train the fight if it's if
it's the you know the latter
cool it's cool well what are we talking
for but you want to fight so go fight
now you go sub novice and every time we
talk you know it's he's got he's got a
reason why he hasn't done it yet and I'm
like no just take the fight just do it
and when you notice that a lot of people
live like that because execution is
scary every every idea is a good idea in
your head
and there are some people who are not
able to deal with the idea that perhaps
it's not the best idea
perhaps reality is going to go you know
let's go back to the drawing board with
this one it's terrifying represent like
like it represents so much of what we're
afraid of wasted time rejection
embarrassment
but the people who get farted are the
ones that Embrace that in fact you know
one of my favorite sayings is look when
you living true to yourself you look
forward to being rejected because that
is that's the most efficient way to cut
out the fluff when someone like like
when you know it is not a good idea when
you know it's not going to work when you
know and then you know that because the
market it says yo this is some [ __ ]
uh you can go back with it but if you
take it personally you'll never do it
and that's the problem people take it
personally give her her story Elon Musk
uh when they started boring company no
so he's at SpaceX and uh
at some point putting tunnels
becomes a topic of discussion and uh my
theory is that they're practicing for
Mars because they believe that we're
gonna have to uh be underground for some
period of time and so if you want to get
good at uh doing tunnels on Mars you
probably should start on Earth uh but
other people say it's because of traffic
or whatever the the reasoning is
but uh they're talking about it he
basically says to a room of Engineers or
whatever he says all right figure out uh
you know could we dig a tunnel and so
they talk for a few minutes or whatever
I suppose if somebody says to them uh
all right I think we could figure this
out he goes uh when can we get started
they say uh it takes about two weeks
and it's on Friday and he says how about
you go out in the parking lot right now
and see how far you get by Sunday
and they literally within two hours they
were out in the parking lot digging a
hole in the ground to see how big of a
hole they could dig
and it's like two weeks to most people
would be like they were moving and he
was like write this [ __ ] second go
outside in the parking lot don't worry
about permits don't worry about getting
equipment not just go outside with
whatever we got and see how far we could
dig by Sunday and that look this is
something I struggle with too that speed
of implementation
because because look the the sooner you
do it the sooner you give me and look it
might be a great idea by itself you
don't need to add anything else
you might discover something you didn't
even that you you we can come over come
on I always used to think about this and
uh
when they're when they're doing quality
uh testing for video games like how they
they figure out all the ways this can go
wrong I always wondered that but they
have a bunch of beta testers they like
they know they know how it should work
right
based on their design and what they
think
and even even with their simulations but
until you get real people and they're
testing and going they have no idea and
that's why they're that testing period
they discover and fix these things it's
the same way with anything that goes on
in your head you you get to it you just
get out there and go quick and and look
I I am not the biggest offender anymore
I'm getting better but that planning
phase is to stay overrated is incorrect
because you need something but you need
a lot less especially when especially
when the cost for failure is so low
you know it's not like it's not like
heart surgery like this is a pretty big
penalty if you you know you go in there
you get a bunch of people and you're
going to figure this out oh now let's
get the butter knife and we'll just see
what happens but but when it comes to
something like like starting a company
or writing or not even something like
that you know just it's not a website
you want to write start a website right
just get out there because the cost of
you making a mistake is so low but what
you learn the experience you get is so
hard
there really isn't a better way we're
gonna do go study right for four years
and what your degree are now I'm
qualified right now it doesn't work that
way real world I think that's one of the
biggest changes in the real world now
is that we have moved from your your
credentials
mattering to you watching people who
know a lot less in the same field that
you study making real big moves I mean
it would it would absolutely I don't
even know how one gets here but uh I
would I would just be sitting there kind
of hot if I'm watching right if I study
marketing for four years uh at a college
paid like 120 000 and I come on there's
this 19 year old kid that's figured out
all I got to do is make some catchy
videos on Tick Tock and put a link in
the description hold up
if you think about it that is right now
I think a lot of uh Street versus The
Boardroom like my entire not my entire
world view but a lot of my world view is
informed by those two things which is
the there's the street approach this is
Street mentality there's the street you
know like all these different components
to life and then there's the boardroom
and what does the boardroom do they
plant what does a street do action right
board room they sit there and they say
okay well you need the credentials you
need this the street says hey you got
the product or do you not right I mean
it's like it's like a very different
view of the world but that but marketing
is a great example I actually think
today the person who is able to I don't
know take a Twitter account or Tick Tock
account or whatever
and then say to a company hey in three
months I went from nothing to 50 000
followers here's the engagement all this
stuff and another person shows up and
says I went to Harvard for marketing
obviously the company picks the uh the
person at least the company should yeah
yeah at least they should like like my
website you know the Google is
been Google and what that means is that
once the technology really became viable
to implement Mass like like we've always
we've always had
to my understanding
uh
gpt3 or something side effect uh pretty
much the predictive kind of this is what
the right and the ability to read and
kind of figure out what words mean
quickly and and that's like a
combination of a huge database and
processing power and then I guess on the
on the last thing you need
um some conduit like like fast internet
right okay so you see this with Google
translate and that's what Google
translate does and how it gets better
and how it kind of figures out the
difference between regions and and
that's why like you can you can type
something in today and get one
translation and then six months get a
better one because it is in a sense
learning and this and I bring this up to
say that is the basis as I understand it
for a lot of the updates Google has made
to the algorithm for it's it searches
you know they go in there and tweak what
they want it to emphasize and downgrade
like for example it made a big
adjustment back in 2019 or 2018 where
you know if we were talking about health
stuff but you didn't have the the
credentials behind it like it was a DOT
edu or dot gov or or some oh like WebMD
or something like that you know you were
downright because they're like yo these
people you know have credibility you're
just the site
let's figure it out no matter how well
it's written what I bring all this up
these changes wiped out a lot there were
a lot of people that enjoy you know had
their websites and blogs people were
complaining
the these changes you know disrupted
everything because it wasn't just like
that's just the field I used medicine
but you know the like Finance uh it took
hits too all of these well I'm I'm not
gonna give up because that's my side we
took a hit man we we did I was cruising
along about to crack 20 000 followers
for visitors per month organic and then
we just got we got dinged and I was like
all right what are we gonna do well I'm
Gonna Learn SEO I'm gonna learn the
street way though it's pretty much what
I did man because everything in my mind
I'm actually like putting together now
so I can teach somebody directly and
then from there I'll probably produce a
product but but I I learned a lot about
how SEO works because I had a vested
interest in having my site my site work
and on the last I checked you know this
is over
three years almost now but been figuring
out taking different things learning
seeing what works with dozen and
figuring out tools well now it's 60 000
visitors per month organic uh and that
is because I didn't give up and it
continues to bump and bump and go up but
it's all from it's all from that street
approach
i i in fact I didn't take
any classes
until like even someone's course I
didn't I didn't do anything probably
until the last three months when I was
rolling my way up but I was like oh
let's let's learn see if there's
anything I don't know because I've been
I've been figuring out a lot here let's
see who you know who else knows what and
I think that's really the best approach
even learning learning works this way I
think great too because because uh every
time I come to Miami I'm reminded of
sometimes I feel good about my Spanish
and other times I'm just like
okay right
but but the way you know what I
discovered a method on on YouTube I was
like wow this guy's brilliant he put
together this thing where he made where
he took himself to fluent in French and
Spanish in 45 days right wow now he did
it devoted eight hours per day
which I don't you know have but you look
at it and using pool a lot from it and
one of the things I took from it this
was so cool uh one of the things you do
you sit and you tell a story very
personal to you all you just need to
have the ability in the language to
construct a sentence and when you don't
know the word you want to use for the
story you write that down you put in the
translate you pop it into the Anki deck
so you can re-re uh review it review it
and then you come back and you just keep
trying to tell the same story you can
tell the same storytelling story until
it feels until you can go through the
whole story and then a funny thing
happens with this very simple bump into
the wall method as opposed to studying
different things uh one you've got a
working vocabulary and it's personal to
you because you're telling a story like
like the first story I put together was
like like the first date with me and my
wife now and I'm like
oh now I know these words I I thought I
I knew when I didn't know but but now I
have it because it's very personal to me
and then the tense of speaking and all
that but I picked it up from bumping
into the wall okay that's that's so much
better than how we typically go about
teaching language which is
go and learn some grammar and here are a
bunch of senses that mean nothing to you
so why would you remember them like you
know even dude I don't love Duolingo
dueling it was based in Pittsburgh I
better loved Duolingo right uh even
Duolingo like because it's just an
interphase and it's good for some things
they no method can do this where you
have where you put together a vocabulary
and an approach that's that's valuable
to you that has that has meaning to you
when you do that combined with just
trying to bump into the wall trying to
talk to people and use these words then
you really and then you start to feel
confident and then you then you can go
okay let me look at a book because I'm
like man I have no idea how to how to
use the the imperfect for this verb and
let me go look this up now but you you
get a feeling that you you need
something like what you do for there uh
but for a new situation and you know how
to find it so bump it into the Wall
Street Method however you want to call
it I call it bumping into the wall but I
think I'm gonna start calling it The
Street Method uh is a lot better I've
always thought of these people as uh
googlers now that term was co-opted by
the company Google that's what they call
their employees or googlers but put that
aside for a second they got the pinwheel
they didn't know that I'm gonna have to
remember that because yeah they call
themselves googlers uh and they got the
uh you ever seen uh I forget what the uh
uh what the comedy uh movie is but uh
they got the pinwheel hat you know like
the multi-colored hat and he's got the
little thing that spins yeah that's real
they give those to the googlers
um but uh uh I was a googler as you ever
like hang out with somebody and uh they
just constantly on their phone or their
computer but it's everything you talk
about they don't know something they
immediately just go and they look it up
I love those people it's so much we have
like the world's knowledge at your
fingertips I I love this man because
I'm always in awe of Technology like
like I never stop being in all the world
on my minute I mean we were in Juno and
I just was watching the planes coming I
was like man we figured out how to put a
metal tube that weighs tons into the air
full of people so and and stuff like
that it makes me feel at all like
whenever I read about uh old cities and
I'm like man we have sanitation and
plumbing like you can like go to the
bathroom and it's not wind up on the
street like that's cool one of the
things that just amazes me is that we
have this handheld handheld not this big
old room a handheld device and in that
handheld device you are simultaneously
connected to every other human on the
planet who has one and we and they all
have one because you need them now and
the whole sum of human knowledge is at
your disposal all you have to do is
develop the skills to ask the right
questions
and Google has a commercial incentive to
make sure they figure out how to best
pair your your question with the best
answer
and if they did you know if you really
wanted to dig deep you just go in a dark
way or figure things out things like
that but there's so many resources in so
many ways like there's no reason to not
know anything it's crazy like every time
someone goes out I'm not sure oh let me
just look it up and there were a few
situations where it's inappropriate to
put my phone on look it up
so there's no there's no reason to ever
like doubt facts and you know and then
from there and people go that makes the
quite the conversation drop like no no
no no no no we don't have Converse
conversations to discuss and swap facts
we have conversations to connect and and
see perspectives and and understand one
another it puts the focus back on the
conversation why you have it if you
don't have to debate a fact and it also
adds clarity
Sports is the place where you see this
the most people start debating each
other they're pulling all the stats
right whatever
um the other thing around technology uh
I'm reading a book right now called the
rise and fall of American growth which
is absolutely uh the worst book if you
want to be entertained but it's you know
700 pages of super dense information all
about the economy and and all this stuff
and somebody recommended to me and I've
enjoyed it so far but the reason why I
enjoy it is the lessons are pretty
simple like his argument is basically uh
economists think that economies grow
forever uh as long as no one touches
them I disagree like that's basically
hero 700 pages on it right but the book
is littered with all these super
interesting facts so one of them is uh
in like 1908 the Ford Model T comes out
uh it was 950 by 1923 15 years later
they'd gotten the cost down 70 percent
like 269 dollars well well they used a
uh a manufacturing method where there
there was a line of people who were
manufacturing the product and you just
did the doors right and like okay well
that's how we manufacture everything
today there was literally somebody who
pioneered that implemented it and now
that is how manufacturing is done then
they talk uh in the book I think it's
like 1870 or so uh which we think of
like the 1800s 150 years ago right
all homes were completely disconnected
from the world you had an outhouse you
had water that you had to go get like
you had to be self-sufficient
by 1940 which again sounds like kind of
a crazy thing but it's only 70 years
pretty much all homes in any urban area
had water gas electricity like they were
hooked up now right or what they call
networked and so you think man 70 years
when someone was born it was
self-sufficient completely unconnected
world before they died
everything was completely different
and so you're like okay like that's a
lot of change but then he makes an
argument where he says
the speed of Transportation has not
changed since 1950.
when we went from the stagecoach to
automobiles
automobile is not like awesome we're all
going 200 miles an hour right like they
pretty much have been going the same
speed you know since the 50s okay
planes
the Boeing 707 is the example he uses
it's like 1953 or whatever uh goes about
the same speed it's not like we're
making these you know 10x improvements
over what is now 70 years in the speed
of Transportation
and so his point is basically like
there's very compacted time where
there's immense Innovation uh uh
inventions progress like all these
changes how many go like really long
periods of time nothing happens
and so for you and I we think about like
Google's like a [ __ ] crazy thing
right yeah and it is around information
and Technology you know like this
information technology world
but if we actually sat here and we're
like What are the major innovations that
we've seen in like the physical world
over the last you know 50 years
sure Tesla with the electric car like we
can come up with a couple a few yeah
self the smartphone versus a dumb phone
like you know like [ __ ] like that right
okay I got it
but not like the invention of [ __ ]
electricity
in fact I think the last thing like the
invention of electricity would be like
that's the time of the internet
right and even that is still a like a
digital thing yeah now it helps right
and this is where it gets kind of a
nuanced conversation because the
internet obviously drastically uh uh
kind of created Innovation all these
industries and all this stuff but like
it is interesting to think about how
many inventions happened in a certain
period of time and then if you think
today like it's not like you and I wake
up every day and we're like damn
somebody created you know
like we get super excited over like
pretty small stuff now and so at least
this conversation around like yeah
everything is digital where all the
innovation's happening are you are you
bumper to this is a new problem and it's
one that like when you you talk about
it's like of course but then until you
you run into it you're like wow this is
really a thing
there are no
there are no physical mediums anymore
that people distribute like like pretty
much the age or physical medium for for
Distributing entertainment is over at
least in terms because we went from
[Music]
VHS DVD
and then they were like yo we can hook
you up with the illegal copies of your
download and download and downloading
Bluetooth
earned blue Blu-ray not Bluetooth
Blu-ray and then full circle because now
everything's digital so now everything
is hidden behind like and now that's
much easier to secure like good luck
travel trying to download stuff now I
mean sure you can but you really got to
be about that life it's not like hopping
on lawn wire or BitTorrent you know
where anyone could do it was a [ __ ]
Lottery
are you getting the virus you didn't
know what you was getting but now you
know it blew my mind I I was thinking
about because we went to a um just to
watch a local band perform and
afterwards they were selling merch
selling copies of their work and they
had CDs and I was like where the hell am
I going to play this
like I never thought about them before
it was like oh do you have the tape then
we've been around long enough to go oh
do they have the tape version I don't
have a CD player yet to oh I'll get the
CD but you have the MP3 now it's like
there's only really one way to get this
though don't give me a CD what I'm gonna
do with this like I can't mark my
MacBook doesn't have one my holder no
none of them you gotta get an extra
piece of Hardware
why would we have that that's that's old
yeah you know the other uh the other
piece I think a lot about
um uh I'm assuming based on our
conversation that uh you read a decent
amount uh do you read physical books you
got Kindle you do audiobooks how do you
consume so okay so it it depends on what
I'm reading I will not read fiction on
on my um
Kindle or my phone okay but non-fiction
I do because it's just easier to take
notes and then transfer those notes out
and then and then on top of that I love
this little thing you do on your Kindle
where you highlight a section and you
can write what you're thinking and type
that in and that really helps me absorb
the information and really helps me
learn it but I won't read fiction that
way I think fiction is fiction is a
special thing and and if we if we
consume it that way I think we've robbed
the specimeness of it which is which is
one it's not a note-taking medium it's
not even the thing you holla I mean
maybe maybe you like see a quote you
really like but then you just go
remember write it down but because I'm
reading it in a physical book then I
know it is this thing I can take with me
and immerse myself into but when I read
on my Kindle I'm automatically thinking
all right there's probably some
information I'm gonna like take down
so I'm not not reading it with the with
the undiluted Focus that I should that I
you know approach my Fiction with
I don't read fishing so I can't speak
tonight oh well here's uh going back to
our conversation around uh uh I read a
lot yeah but I know what I'm good at I
know what I'm not and for fiction
whatever reason I just it's like a lack
of Interest which is probably makes me
less well-rounded but cool that is what
it is right
but the reason why I bring this up uh
uh three four months ago uh up until
then I pretty much read everything
either some sort of Kindle type device
or whatever or audiobooks I did a lot of
audio books I sat down and tried to read
the physical book my head hurt
I couldn't concentrate no kidding and it
like pissed me off I was like what do
you mean I can't sit and just read a
book I literally could not read the book
my my head started hurting my eyes were
hurting like all of a sudden my eyes
hurt sometimes just like the fluorescent
lights or whatever right but like I was
like this is [ __ ] like I think I was
like mad at myself right so for the last
like three four months I only will read
the physical books now I've like forced
myself to be able to read the physical
books now and uh so over the weekend
um I was on a flight and I listened to
audiobook first of all I listened and I
felt like I was on crack
oh [ __ ] this is 2xb like I was blowing
through this book right but then what it
goes back to is like I don't know if
retention wise like maybe I get like 90
retention out of the physical book maybe
it's like 75 in that audio so it's like
it's pretty similar but definitely a
little less on audio
um
but the physical book it made me think I
was like all this technology all this
information at our fingertips all these
things
like the physical book made my head hurt
yeah and all we hear about is how the
computers are going to make our heads
and our eyes hurt
there's some
some interesting
I guess you know a week or maybe week
maybe strong correlations whatever right
but we we talk about
there's this rise in ADHD diagnosis and
it's like and it doesn't really make
sense when you look at it it goes okay
we've known about this thing forever and
all of a sudden uh skyrocketing
um skyrocketing the amounts of diagnoses
and I only know about this in context to
a speech I gave about uh how how boys
are treated like kind of like defective
girls in the school system and one of
the points I raised and how I found that
data was that this raising ADHD boys are
represented four to five times more uh
than girls but you know it's a rising
title and all all fronts
and I think about this a lot in terms of
screens
because
although we're looking at this thing and
and in an Ideal World you know we're
just focusing on pulling it in
I think by Nature with screens do you
know what the notable exception you know
being if you read your Kindle that way
um well no screen even with the Kindle
but you can swipe your screens
allow you to change the speed they allow
you to be distracted typically however
you want to be they they change how you
bring in the information and if you're
still bringing the information I mean
something has to fundamentally change
about how you're processing it
and when you go back to a book without
those things I think my guess would be
that it's it's it's like uh it's like
the opposite of training with weights on
and then you go take the weights off
where you go on faster I'm like yeah
it's great because you're in control of
it but if you remove all these stressors
uh then you can't in fact here's a great
analogy and I just thought about this
there's this great book called The
epidemic of absence non-fiction if you
want to check it out the basic the basic
thesis of the epidemic of absence is
that uh our immune systems
evolved in a hostile environment full of
pathogens full of disease full of Filth
whatever right and now that that we
don't have that we live in a clean
Society you see that's why you see this
rise of allergies because the the immune
system is like yo I need to I need to
give me something right that looks
that's a protein it looks kind of like
the other proteins and viruses and
bacteria I'll Attack it and so you get
your allergies to you know shellfish and
eggs or milk Etc right and that's the
other and then like the author goes and
like infects himself with a tapeworm and
attempts down his allergies to his hay
fever and stuff like that but um I think
about that a lot
especially in in this context which is
we have this our immune system didn't
take a break
it didn't change
our environment changed and it was like
I'm going to attack something else and
that thing is typically helpful to you
but it looks close enough like what I'm
used to dealing with let me go do
something let's take that up that that
uh
analogy and well and we we use it for
for really you get used to pulling in
your information just right there in
front of your face
you devote all your mental activity to
it because that's what you'd have to do
to read I mean like I think reading what
musical is probably a relatively new
thing but but I can see how
um it's it's possible without it
interfering too much but I know like I
have trouble reading this right like
especially uh music with with words in
it I couldn't do it I looked this up
recently because I thought to myself as
I was trying to figure out the book I
said I wonder if uh it's better or worse
and as you just alluded to with words uh
scientifically is shown to distracts
your brain it it screws up your ability
to read uh uh but even music without
words
yeah because the distraction it gives me
like you you have this method of pulling
in information
total focus and then you bring in a new
method that by its very nature of design
comes with a new you're not turning
Pages you're able to kind of skim not as
much as on in front of you at the same
time as it would be with a with a book
uh uh you have all these new things that
aren't necessarily uh improvements in
the sense of they make you a better or
more efficient reader maybe faster but
not necessarily more efficient because
your brain's like
well I'm gonna give you I gotta do
something give me something and there's
only so many words I can pull in here
all right we're gonna mess with your
eyesight you know uh or we're gonna
we're gonna make you um
every time you see something you're
looking up immediately and get pulled
out and we know how long it takes for
you to get your your focus back when
it's broken or something and it's so you
may not even be able to focus as long as
you used to be able to because your
focus is now used to being broken and
broken I broke it up
whenever you get a push notification or
something like that or you want to look
something up or you want to highlight
something that's very unnatural to to
highlight while you're reading we're
used to just pulling in information but
uh this is all just my my um I never put
these two things together before but in
this conversation putting these ideas
together uh that that that's my guess
that's what I would that that is I think
or at the very least that's an
interesting explanation and it's an
easily testable one what happens when
you go back to reading uh without I
enjoy it yeah and you're able to you're
able to focus a lot more at imagine
the um uh one of the science uh research
kind of paths that I find fascinating is
um there's a lot of work uh stoics
there's uh Ryan holiday's written books
like all the stuff around just like uh
uh Focus Stillness like all this type of
stuff can lead to more idea generation
or whatever so if you basically sit for
30 minutes while a lot of people get
ideas in the shower right because
they're not doing anything else their
mind kind of wanders they think of
something whatever
but there's also a bunch of research
around walking
and so the walking becomes really
interesting because uh you could take a
person and they aren't moving that is
the least you know kind of beneficial
thing and then the other extreme is that
they're literally walking outside but
there's this Middle Ground what about
walking on like a treadmill right or
like oh you got these standing walking
desks whatever it's actually shown that
part of the value of walking to the
brain is one there's a physical
component but two is actually the
movement forward and so the research
unlocks saying like no if you're gonna
walk away get your ass outside and walk
not mimic almost like a lab rat you know
walking on the trail now it's better
than sitting or you're just standing
there uh but the benefit to actually
walking and moving through the
environment your brain does something
different than just walking on like a
treadmill stationary
it's fascinating not only that and this
is this is a rare case I can remember
the name of the author and not the book
I can't even see the cover of the book
in my head weird but Barbara Oakley is
the the author and she writes about
learning it might be that the science of
learning something that affect I'm not
sure but Barbara Oakley is the is the
author and she talks about the the fuse
monster versus the focus and when we're
focused we're like trying what we're
like the analogy she gave was was the
focus this is you you're looking at each
individual Dot and trying to navigate
around it and figuring out on diffuses
where you step back and you see this
whole pattern and you see the whole
layout you may not be thinking about how
to get through it but you're just
absorbing your brains kind of working on
the on the the process to get through it
in the background one of the things that
walking does showering does doing
anything else but working on the
immediate problem does is that it lets
it lets you kind of step back and it's
always there it's in the back of your
mind otherwise it's not important but
then when you're not thinking about it
that's when you make these connections
that you couldn't see kind of like you
know the whole Force for the trees
analogy when you're looking at the
individual trees because you're trying
to get out the forest you don't realize
the path the the most optimal path to
follow unless you know it
but if you step back and you're or step
up in this case or raise up and you're
able to look down and see oh the path is
really clear but now you're out the
force how are you going to communicate
it Donna hopefully you carry it but it's
but it's only
uh it's only in that diffuse mode that
we make a lot of
the these connections that we're able to
see how things work and play together
like I mean I wasn't even thinking about
the epidemic of absence and I make this
connection to reading and those are two
two fields that don't really well why
would they ever match but you know
because I I was thinking talking about
this and this is in the background and
that's like an analogy kind of like a
mental model that I that I use a lot
that I find a lot of people don't have
which is that you know the the idea that
a thing has a purpose and when you
remove that purpose the thing doesn't
change it just figures out another way
to to do what it thinks it's supposed to
do
these connections get made it's
um tool versus environment a lot of
times right and uh um I I always think
of it uh in the most extreme situation
right so I just jumped with extreme so I
can take a gun and all the gun debate
and also that goes on in America today
right it's like look there's a lot of
different tools but uh they use for good
or bad and uh that doesn't mean
necessarily that we shouldn't address
the use of the tool or that certain
people should have access or not have
access or whatever like there's all this
Nuance you and I aren't going to solve
this whatever
but it always shocks me as to the level
of uh uh Elementary analysis I was I was
gonna say binary thinking yeah just just
like like yo this is a tool like can we
all at least at least agree on that part
which is a important almost building
block to have a discussion around what
should the rules be and there's like a
whole group of people who's like no it's
not a tool exactly and it's really hard
here because
you know something when you when you
learn is that something they tell you
you just kind of take the face value
they tell you that intelligence is
normally distributed
you just take that phrase value because
most people are never going to have the
the opportunity to verify that at all to
put it to the test and then you get on
social media and you have a large
following a large a lot of interactions
and you realize holy [ __ ] this is not
only is this true it might actually be
exaggerated
[Music]
um
and one of the the difficulties humans
have and I have no idea what like or if
there's even an IQ level or something
like that or cut off point is is to
consider
contrary thoughts without being attached
to
our well the ability to detach their
personality from the thought their ego
because I think that's what what uh
inhibits a lot of constructive
discussion is people if I if I'm
pro-second Amendment
and and I make you know guns are part of
my identity right that's who I am I
can't entertain any discussion that
might reduce my access to them or anyone
else's access to them
I can't do it if I see that as part of
my personality and I'm not open to to
any way to actually make
um make the world a better place by
perhaps making you know perhaps by being
more pro-gun you know as weird as that
sounds people go okay I'm gonna have to
give ground well what if you don't have
to give ground what if the ground you
think you're giving actually makes your
position stronger you know I'm I like I
have this time all the time of people
about about guns guns just a great way
it's the most extreme case right yeah
well not only is the most extreme it's
really uh an easily
disgustable one because we have so many
examples and and so many
um not just examples of when things go
wrong are are right interestingly enough
though for things to go right they have
to be wrong but that's a a different
discussion but we also have a lot of
different debates we've seen and have
them pop up but but if you if you
entertain the idea for example this is I
was man funny how relevant these things
happened I was just having a discussion
I said look I'm almost pro-gun is is is
anyone you know can be
but I think if you're gonna have a gun
you need to train with that thing have
you ever like like have you really ever
gone in this one my instructor tells me
this all the time most people don't go
to the range and they need to go to the
range because when I bring up everyone
goes oh they they cite you your boy I
think it was down in Texas maybe or
Illinois to where he shot the guy who
was going to do a shooting in the mall
and I go look you gotta understand I
don't know where that guy got his
training or where he trained but that is
a trained dude it's like 40 yards he hit
him like eight out of times
15 yards the average person is not going
to even hit the target let alone oh
Center Mass it's not happening so so all
I proposed I said look everybody who has
a gun they should they should have to
keep they should have to put in training
hours I really believe that this
shouldn't be walking around with
something that can end the life with
just that with just pulling a trigger
and you don't and you don't have to
train with it and the blowback I got on
this idea
they're like I don't think people should
have to train I don't think people you
know if they if they want to have a gun
it's our God can run I'm like I'm not
telling you to give up your guns what
I'm saying is you you'll actually be a
better gun owner like you do you realize
that
and and it didn't they couldn't give any
ground on everyone should have guns I I
always like to ask people who seem to be
uh kind of uh dug in on a topic you know
so let's take a a very pro-gun person I
would ask them is there ever an instance
where you think somebody should not own
a gun yeah right like just like just
Again by the way uh they'll be like no
I'm like all right so uh if somebody has
killed multiple people before has a
documented mental illness like you know
like just go to the extreme right like
do you think that person have a gun if
they say yes I'm done talking to you
yeah
and then you go to the other end though
right you said that the anti-gun people
is there ever a situation where you
think somebody should be allowed to own
a gun yeah and if they're like no my
okay well what happens if someone is
breaking into your house well your child
will you know all these different things
right and and if they still say no I
don't think I should be able to defend
themselves okay I'm done talking to you
know that's a great great tactic that's
probably gonna save me a lot because my
my weakness on there I'm I'm one of the
I would like to think anyhow uh I'm one
of the more patient
respectful people on the internet that
that's changed a little bit about but
only because one of the cool things
about about knowing you every kid or no
is you start thinking about what's
important yeah I'm like your stupid
opinion isn't important to me I have no
interest in changing it
that's relatively recent but I'm sure
it'll it'll go I'll go back to my
Baseline but I I tend to give people the
benefit of the doubt and I think overall
that's a that's a good strategy because
it allows me to at least have a
conversation and see where they're at
from a tactical perspective like I have
a good strategy but that's a sound
tactic to ask to start okay do you think
there's ever an instance where you would
change your stance
okay wow and then you give some nope oh
well then we can save ourselves some
time but if we can find that if we can
find some ground we're like yeah I mean
I guess that's common ground like we're
gonna debate about guns and we can both
find that Common Ground there are is
there's a situation where you should not
have one okay now we can talk but if
you're not even you know it's basically
it's my way to filter uh I just want to
know I'm talking to a person who can
have a rational conversation yeah that's
a good way to go like like I have no
interest in talking to irrational people
where it's become a religion right or
it's become like because I never want to
get through to that I don't talk to
people and try to convince them to give
up their religion right right and if you
do that amazing I feel uh if that makes
you happy that that's great I'm guessing
the success record of that is pretty low
right and so if you then just say to
yourself like cool I just want to talk
to people who uh can see a little bit of
nuance that's okay we don't agree but at
least I it's like a good faith
conversation where I know that like all
right right you you see a piece of the
conversation that the most extreme in
your Camp don't see and that then makes
it at least worth the time to start a
conversation you know always by these
conversations are great because once
again a another Insight that just
camerated I never really made on my own
so I think that's that's a defining
characteristic of of someone who would
be considered extremist at least to me
because I'm always really fascinated
with the idea of one what makes a person
extreme and and to do do people who who
are on their side but not as extreme see
them as extreme or not those are two
really interesting a question to me and
that that idea that okay
you can can you see a situation where
your perspective is incorrect
or at the very least your your
perspective is inadequate where there
needs to be a modification uh if you
can't see that then yeah I think that
would qualify as someone who's extreme
but them but if you give you can see how
it'll change and be my you know then
it's it's different and I think I think
that's a really good if I apply that
filter to to a variety of social issues
not you know that we've we Face
everything from from race to to religion
you know to abortion or guns you apply
that filter to to it you can pretty much
suss out relatively quickly who the the
extremists are and who are the people
who can have reasonable conversations I
think that if you take this exact same
framework and during the debates on the
political side
every candidate should have to answer
what is one thing that your candidate
believes that you agree with oh that
goes against your own party
and if you say nothing you're
disqualified
right like like to to some degree
that just that alone like what is
something that the other person believes
that you tend to believe more than what
the standing you know kind of uh Line in
the Sand of the party is but you know uh
politics at least in this country they
they've done a really
it's almost it would be impressive if it
wasn't so destructive
they've made it so so you know there's
the we'll just say left and right there
are The Oddities on the left and the odd
is on the right all right and the odds
of you you know if you would leave one
idea on the left the odds you believe in
the other ideas are pretty high whether
that's accurate or not as irrelevant
what is relevant is that I can typically
with some accuracy and consistency uh if
I know how you feel it one thing I don't
know how you feel on a bunch of other
things okay they've weaponized this
because now you can't if you're if
let's say you're left leaning on
on the abortion issue right but you're a
pro-gun pick one you can be both even
though those things are not related uh
you you're either gonna be a you got to
decide are you going to go on everything
for the left everything on the right but
they're not going to let you mix and
match and people who do that they they
almost
in there well I can insult almost like
censor centers because because you know
no one wants to be called a Libertarian
anymore because now they're trying to
make that like
oh just just a way to be a right winger
so they they say because they don't they
don't want that neutrality you know even
even street gangs recognize neutrality
man but not not the thing um that I do
uh believe is a very powerful force in
politics right now which no one is uh uh
uh acknowledging or talking about
is the weaponization of extremism
where there's pulling to the extremes
which I think people recognize that and
they say Okay ex candidate or ex uh
politician they are on the extreme of
that party right so we recognize that
but what people aren't yet talking about
is the labeling of extremism so the
right winger thing is like a perfect
example where it doesn't matter what you
actually believe
right like uh uh I've heard Joe Rogan
talk about uh the fact that they were
like oh this right-leaning uh Republican
people he's like I'm looking for [ __ ]
Democrats my entire life right yep and I
don't know maybe it's a Nostalgia or
whatever but 20 years ago if somebody
came out and said I am a Democrat I vote
for Democrats I whatever then like
people like that's a Democrat that
doesn't happen now it's all about the
labels the label is actually almost more
important than I thought and now in
Reverse it works the same way
the right will label certain people and
say uh that's socialist that's all you
know whatever the terminology uh uh that
kind of proves the point and so if you
kind of again just take a step back and
you look at kind of the whole playing
field what you realize is it's not about
the truth nope it has nothing to do with
the truth this is all a propaganda war
that is being fought by two different
factions and if it wasn't in the United
States if we looked at it and this was
Iraq for example you know what the
storyline would be in the United States
the two warring factions yeah led by you
know like like the language would be so
different we would all sit there in the
United States and we'd be like that's
crazy
and move on with our day because it's
our politics we know one no one sees it
you know
one of the one of the observations I
made you know that
look here's the here's the problem would
be in a uh call it if I I would like to
consider myself a free thinker now I
will also say at the same time a lot of
people consider themselves free thinkers
happen all think the same and don't you
think that's funny but uh canceled
but but one of the things about about
being black because you're expected to
think and tow a certain line and I think
that's that's one of the most
destructive things that that can happen
is people look at me
um and and when I say people I mean
I mean a a general group of politically
motivated people who see who see me
being black as a as a um a card to play
they get them on our size big platform
whatever okay but
when I when I question things that that
I go well that's not racist right you
know and you're trying to get them to
pin down a definition of racism and then
they can't do that I think one of the
the dangers
here and I get to say it because I'm or
at least I used to now and now I'm an
uncle Tom and a [ __ ] I bring it up but I
I can say
that's not racist like you might not
like how it feels but wait let's not
throw in call the races and here's the
thing when you call everything
uh there's a slight against you when you
when you're trying to put a racial spit
on it then what happens is actual racism
is Con that gets to slip in because you
don't even recognize it anymore like
there's this great video
um about the voter ID laws where God
goes and asks a bunch of a bunch of uh
people on Berkeley's campus what they
think about voter ID laws and everyone's
like oh you know they they
disproportionately affect minorities
because they have less money and they
they can't figure out the internet and
they can't go and learn go get to the
DMV and so we need these and I'm sitting
here listen I'm like do you hear yours
like you know you don't hear
like that's the real racism to assume
that because and then he goes by
contrast and goes into Harlem and ask
someone's black people like yeah I know
where the DMV is
like everybody's got the idea you can't
even get you can't buy alcohol
everything so so I thought that was like
when I saw that I was like wow
um because we're not but because we're
not allowed to
question are they trying to make it so
you you know you you can't question
things or pin down definitions and
that's a totally different conversation
uh the manipulation of our language and
really trying to make it ambiguous so
that it can fit whatever purpose we
needed to fit all right let's call let's
call it races when we introduce you know
when we oppose something called voter ID
law but it's not racist when you go over
the reasons which oh sitting around
degrading are there at least you know
pointing out our lack of function that's
why we need it we obviously can't get to
the DMV
um then we have a problem and so that is
that is one of the other problems with
politics today is is the manipulation of
these labels and I think words are
powerful man I think that's why I'm
drawn to them because I understand how
powerful they are and if you watch it's
the manipulation of these things is
incredible did you see
uh black lives matter
donation slash lawsuit yep so I don't I
don't know a ton about this I saw a
headline I think I read two paragraphs I
want to be careful that I don't [ __ ] up
any of the facts frankly okay
um but there was one specific sentence
in this in this statement
that my head was in a blunder I I
couldn't understand
kind of how this all all plays out so I
would love to hear kind of you Riff on a
little bit
there's two I guess factions right that
kind of come out of the situation there
was a bunch of money that was donated uh
one of the co-founders being accused of
taking or using 10 million dollars it's
basically a personal slush fund yeah
that's my words not theirs but that was
just the general uh kind of accusation
that individual appears to almost be
saying like oh uh the other group is
using the white man system to oppress me
and so when I saw like it just like on
that alone it was just one of these
situations where I was just like
holy [ __ ] we're headed into a world like
I don't even worry about like today it's
like 10 years from now
it almost gets to the point where like
it will be impossible to navigate the
world without offending someone
that's about design or not that's a
different conversation but
wow
when you when you when you decide the
words don't
when you strip away the meaning of a
word right are you modified slightly
but there's a consistency we we
understand that that's that's what a
dialect kind of is you know you use
these words a certain way and we all
agree with that what they mean the
problem is uh when you are allowed to
change them whenever the situation suits
you and then no one calls you out or
checks you on it like like oh press
who's oppressing you you have 10 million
dollars man like
that's like it's crazy that one can go
and he can say that with a straight face
because look you know hopefully
hopefully you know the the powers that
be take care of this problem but let's
navigate the mindset to get you to the
point where you think that's that's an
okay different like like and probably
genuine believer I don't I don't think
it's a cop-out that's another important
piece of a lot of things not not just
race related just like across Society I
do always ask myself
um given the facts that are publicly
known
does it appear that this person actually
believes what they're saying yeah and I
actually do think in most cases people
do believe what they're saying which
almost makes it crazier oh yeah right
because you're like oh no that person
really believes that they're wrong
they're like completely wrong but they
do believe what they're like you can
correct
ignorance all right the very least you
can remedy you know by by putting the
correct information in front
but but Insanity uh you like you almost
by definition you can't really do
anything about that so so when a person
says that they really think they're
being oppressed that they really think
they suffered at the hands of something
you know how do you prove to them that
they haven't how do you get them to go
no it's not quite that way yeah you
can't do it so you know what man the the
whole BLM thing
um
I used to think
it was just somebody's really bad
marketing and that's what they called a
BLM because because if I'm going to
attack it like let's let's say I'm an
opponent and I'm going to attack I'm
gonna go whoa oh they're they're you
know Chiraq was on fire this weekend
well you know and there was a lot of
black lives you know do those not matter
but they really matter when they're
taking out the hands of what you believe
is someone who you can you know profit
from and Route people up I used to think
that was just bad marketing and now I'm
I'm almost 100 convinced it's
intentional you call it this good name
and that and in that sense it's
brilliant marketing you you call it this
name
it's very easy to get mine very simple
black lives matter let's just get out
there they matter
and then in the fine print that no one
sees no reason they matter when the
police officers shot them his wife when
the crime to happen against somebody was
perceived to be by another model well by
by white men and we're not going to
worry about any of the interpersonal
violence
um or our interracial violence and
things like that uh because that's not
important and we can't profit from that
right that's like I mean that's how the
farm prayer has to read based on their
actions and I try to have this
discussion with somebody uh who's very
Pro uh come pro black lives matter I was
like wow you know we just had this crazy
shooting and we're gonna see them show
up here but I know it's for the police
I'm like well why are they called that
you know and then and that is the Power
of Words you gotta put you you get
people who logically will will you can
you can get them to follow it like okay
they're not showing up when there are
other crimes well when they're when
they're violence when there's violence
in Black communities at the hands of
other black people uh and we can we can
get them to logically take that step but
then when I get them to go so we can
agree that it's not that black lives
matter it's that when there's a
situation we can spin oh I won't even
say spin that's my worst but they only
matter when the people who are taking
them are not black and you can like see
the breakdown because the either they
admit that and I'm right or it's in
denial and the concept is wrong like in
general just
not right whether they can't give and so
they just go back and now we're talking
more about people who can't you know
yeah the um the other situation uh and I
always get so nervous that I'm I
misspeak on uh on the exact details so
this is a general recollection of it but
the kid who his mom like drove him
across uh state lines he had a gun he
was at one of the protests uh he shot
and killed two people uh I think it was
the Kennesaw uh oh yeah Rittenhouse
writtenhouse Kyle Rittenhouse yeah so I
remember when like the trial happened I
believe he shot two white people oh yeah
it's crazy isn't it
no no and people on Twitter were like
hold on that's not what we were told and
this is something because I followed
this like
probably as closely as you'll ever get
me following mainstream news it doesn't
affect me
um because now I was curious because I
didn't know things and and I wanted to
see like what's the what's to do is are
we going to see okay but here's the
thing I'm not
one way we got to make sure Justice
is uh is distributed well and and be
aware of that because it's important for
people who do wrong things to be
punished right because if he if he was
out there just randomly shooting black
people right that's a big deal if they
let them off any but but it's also a big
deal if he's like nah we got to figure
out what it is and so when you go when
you go and learn the details of the case
and and the background of him you know
this is a guy who like had been talking
about
black well I was mad at themselves white
kid and don't have the as I remember he
was either donating or contributing or
clean it up but but he did shoot you
know white guys and so that's a that's a
great spin because you know what what
did Mark Twain say man alive is halfway
around the world before the truth gets
his shoes on and that was before the
internet
so so now
you got people going up into the truck
really believe that and I didn't and I
didn't dig too deeply into it but then
when I found out I was like okay let me
follow this little one closely because
there's a lot to learn here and then you
still you stay the whole state lines
thing you know I believe that was his I
think there was his grandmother or
Father's neighborhood it wasn't like he
was just randomly on a bus was like I'm
gonna go hunting like nah
I I uh that was the one time where I I
seems like similar to you and they're
like I don't really pay that much
attention to like the national news
about a lot of this stuff and uh frankly
the most interest that I have in you
know kind of what I'd consider more
local Regional things that blow up to
the National level is like oh there's a
police chase like there's a cool video
right here which like you know good or
bad whatever that's human nature like
there there's some crazy thing that ends
up being entertainment unfortunately for
for some portion of the population
but this one uh
I don't know if it was because it was
being pushed so hard by the national
Media or whatever but like I feel like I
kind of popped my head up and I was like
oh that's uh not exactly what I what my
assumptions were what I had thought I uh
were the facts or whatever and then it
was kind of one of these things like I
couldn't wait to like pull my head back
down and just like hey yeah all right
that's not I don't want to be paying
attention I'm not happy when I'm reading
that stuff every day in terms of like
the national yeah it really messes with
you yeah and it was just one of these
situations where I remember saying to
myself like
for me somebody who's on the internet a
lot uh
and like all right like generally aware
maybe of like the national news stories
I don't pay a lot of attention to them
but like I see what's trending on
Twitter you know all this stuff
if I was that surprised
I didn't even want to go why what was
Fox News saying in MSNBC because again
it's just like the mainstream Twitter
conversation you could see the shock and
like the the outrage probably two
extreme of a word but just like people
being like well there's more here that
maybe we don't understand right that you
could imagine
the extremes of the mainstream media
just pulling every detail spinning it
doing all this stuff and you're just
like
that's just like we're all gonna die one
day I don't want to spend my time trying
to figure out that's how I feel you know
people always ask me today's episode is
brought to you by ftxus they're a safe
regulated way to buy Bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies they've got very cheap
fees sometimes as much as 85 percent
cheaper than their competitors there's
also no minimum fees there's no
withdrawal fees or any other hidden fees
ultimately FTX us is trying to make it
dead simple for you to buy Bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies they also now have
digital stock trading as well with no
transaction fees and no payment for
order flow all you have to do is go
download the FTX app today from the App
Store and use code pop and you'll get
some money back every single time you
trade ten dollars or more again Go
download the FTX app today use code Pomp
and every time you trade 10 or more
they'll go ahead and they'll give you
some crypto back the more you trade the
more you earn download the FTX app today
well not at all they don't always ask me
but but it comes up a lot because I have
been I'm fairly local about it about my
disinterest in politics and current
events and I know that seems weird
because we've just spent the last you
know 20 to 30 minutes discussing these
things but it's only because you you
can't really like it's very hard to be
on the internet
to the level we are and not be at least
aware of things and some things you will
you will dig deeper into because they
they they're just
um for whatever reason whether it's
because the details seem interesting or
or they just won't go away that's a
really the big one oh it just won't go
away
but but for the most part like I I try
to maintain I call it willful and
willful ignorance and active disinterest
and and a lot of the stuff that is on
the the politics and and uh current
media because you know at the end of the
day I figure like this but let's let's
forget the stock Stand start really
believing that which I'm gonna die one
day I would rather enjoy it
if something's a real big deal like real
big deal is going to affect my life I'm
gonna find out like oh uh like like
let's say I didn't know anything about
real ID and I just went on my way
I'm gonna find out uh that my ID is
wrong I might have to do something about
that even if it but because I travel I'm
gonna hear about it anyway you know and
and I think about the number of things
that have happened in in politics that
that bug me or are that affect me not
bugging me that affect me and I'm like I
can't think of much and when they do I
thank goodness I've structured my life
in such a way but if something really
bothers me like it's a really big deal
I'm just gonna leave the country I'll
move to another state you know like like
I am and a lot of people did that over
the last two years right move States not
move States and move country you know I
just seen an article it's trending about
how how Mexico people are complaining in
Mexico City are those too many white
people not Mexico City and like go back
to America and they're like go back and
and it's funny you know I'm seeing that
from Mexico you know Mars Portuguese
we're here record numbers of Americans
in Portugal now yeah but now it's still
a small percentage but a lot of people
leave them but but that's where my
stance is I have I create this agency
around my life
so that I don't have to worry about this
stuff and I think outside of people who
who make a living but by by knowing
knowing the game like like my
brother-in-law he's a wealth planner and
he makes a lot of his decisions on where
to put money at based on what what he
believes the economy will do and he
comes to those conclusions from years of
experience I'm watching the news yeah he
probably should watch it I don't do any
of that so I don't pay attention to him
you know and if it's a big deal I'm
gonna find out my life is gonna get a
real hard reminder uh quickly but
there's one other thing that started to
happen that I noticed and it always
scares me when I notice I got a new uh
reaction to things I see
um but uh it hit home this morning
actually I was uh on Twitter
and I saw a account which uh you know in
the gray areas you know somebody could
double check uh see what's getting
posted uh but they retweeted uh an
account that I've never seen before and
uh it was a video and it said uh I
thought Ukraine was being invaded or
something to that effect and it was uh
allegedly a video of a party in Kiev of
a bunch of what looked like 20 something
year olds partying their faces off
drinking no different than if on Friday
night you went out in Miami and somebody
took a video right and a lot of people
playing beer pong kind of like college
party right
and there was like two or three levels
and I made 50 100 people there not
what we would expect right because on
the same day the same morning I see that
the president of Ukraine is uh ringing
the stock market Bell and and uh
basically pitching on CNBC the uh
investment in Ukraine
I just thought of myself my first
reaction was not good or bad it was is
this video real what's man I mean other
people really look Ukrainian oh like you
know you start thinking to yourself like
ah like what time could this video been
posted like you all of a sudden you like
now we're in this weird world on the
internet of like I don't even know if
that video is really and so you can't
even put the energy right yeah I just
you know yeah I'm trying I'm slightly at
a loss of words only because I have this
this exact reaction to everything in
fact you ever see the Matrix and and the
first time
um Neo meets Morpheus
or not not the first time but it's it's
doing early in their meetings he goes
you have the look of a man who accepts
everything he sees because he's
expecting to wake up
funnily enough that's not too far from
the truth right I'm like
huh that's how I feel about a lot of
stuff I see because you can't you you
don't know you don't know anymore and
then and because so much come out where
the the angle has changed and leaving
out something vital or it's outright
fabricated or or it's an old photo used
to represent something new you just
gotta look at everything with a granite
so and go okay look if I want like if
you win you know how they say if you
want to find something to be angry about
if you want to be angry you'll find
something to be angry about it's a
perfect example you don't know if any
half this stuff is real half the stuff
that comes out is fake like yo it's so
crazy I I'm aware of all the news and
all the numbers around inflation and and
even I have to go sometimes I'm at the
grocery store I'm booking the price and
go is it really that bad anyway because
I'm looking at the meat man and the
price and I know what I paid because you
know I'm just like it's really that bad
or is it really happening and then I
think about 1984 and I think that's a
book everyone should read it's friction
so
all right hey I have right now before
but that when
not really out of war and they break
down the way things really really work
because we just you know we tell
everyone they are and everyone proceeds
if it is it is like that because when
when things are that way you don't have
to innovate you don't have to create you
know it's not good people think you're
at War they just listen and following it
gives it gives everyone the power to
create oh and everyone part of
government to enact laws and we don't
have to worry about Innovation as you
can our citizens I think about that a
lot sometimes like that like you you
could in fact if you don't want to read
anyone listening if you want to like
read 1984 just get to that part where uh
I can't remember the characters anyways
explaining uh how everything really
works when he gets oh I think he finds a
book or something that explains how how
to war and all that is manufactured and
you start and then you start looking
around you go okay this is a little too
close to home uh I'm gonna step back
because
it's really designed I think this I
believe this in my heart of hearts
because because it makes sense following
the money this makes sense forget the
conspiracy angle it makes sense that you
being enraged is good for the Network's
pocket because the networks work on a
CPM model as far as far as I understand
especially on the internet where you
don't even got to buy anything you just
gotta keep reading you just gotta be on
the site
that's what I get paid you go on and
you're gonna go because you're angry and
you got to find out more information
yesterday figured it out let's just put
the most negative extreme Polaris stands
or something almost to the point of it
not being accurate like when you read
what the article is about versus what
the headline says but it's okay because
they got you to click through and read
so there's more money everyone goes I'm
happy when you're angry and polarized do
you remember during 2020 CNN had the uh
I called it the death scoreboard
remember they had that on there they
literally
care of that
number the screen
it showed how many people were and the
reason why I know is uh at the time I
was living in New York and uh in the
building uh there was a TV in the
elevator and they never had anything
else on like oh we I requested like a
hundred times I was like yo can you
please get this because it was
depressing right right it was like man
like this is like not what I want to do
when I get in the elevator is look at
this thing and it was there every day
every day every day and I remember being
like holy [ __ ] like that is in terms of
getting people enraged and holding
attention doing all this stuff that
single thing that's the most Innovative
thing they've ever done you couldn't you
couldn't ask for a better uh piece of I
guess piece of reporting than this
negative Scoreboard on on a very related
note
have you ever seen Anchorman 2.
both funny movies but uh Anchorman 2 is
is really under appreciated because it's
a brilliant piece of social commentary
on how to news spins things to keep you
engaged and when I first seen it at this
point it might be I don't know I feel
like it was it was definitely over 10
years ago probably like 15 at this point
Anchorman too I remember I thought that
when I seen it this is before I got like
really into social media and seen
anything and I was like wow they really
they really summed it up if you can make
people the the the basic premises news
by itself was boring and doesn't keep
people engaged and so we don't lose we
don't make money and we're gonna be off
the network so let's figure out how to
make money oh this is the kind of stuff
we got to cover let's cover that and
that saves the network when you and yeah
when you see that you go why this is
nuts and you know it's funny and so
that's probably why people the main
identity main point but that's what I
took away from in all those years and I
see it in place now I see how it's
working now and yeah that scoreboard
great I did you know what else is a
great idea going back to the race
conversation
let's not report on the shootings
when the perpetrators why are on the
perpetrator when the victim is Right are
the police officers are black we don't
want to report on those those are that's
not good news
all right you know it is good news what
I want a white guy shoots a black dude
like like that video that that story
about them cops beating the crap out I
mean well there's so many I don't even
know what's wrong right uh me makes news
it pops up because it's a violent video
I'm sure the way it goes away
the uh the internet I actually think has
a much better memory now that's true
right because they will uh they'll pop
this stuff up and
um also I think a lot of people on the
internet now have moved from uh
um fact entertainment so I see a lot of
videos on the internet
and if you're like new to the internet
whatever that would mean like you'd be
trying to figure out is that really
where it's from or whatever I saw I
don't know if you saw the uh it's
allegedly a Russian dash cam video where
uh there's like two cars driving at
night one kind of pulls in front of the
other driver hops out in the middle of
the highway it's like banging on the
driver uh door
people get out and they're in like
full-blown Halloween costumes and they
beat them up right and they jump back in
and they take off and it's like the most
amazing dash cam whatever uh and I saw
it recently it was circular circulating
again and uh people are already tweeting
it
and now I just said I'll give a [ __ ]
where that is like that's just funny
yeah right like like strip away all the
like uh uh um kind of chaotic uh like um
sensitivities that everyone's trying to
get everyone enraged or whatever and
it's like by the way the video's
probably fake it's probably staged like
if you look at it through the lens of
like that's a YouTube stunt
all of a sudden now people are like yo
look at this funny ass video and people
man they really coordinating these
YouTube stuff I I only know that because
I just shared this video absolutely
hilarious but but it it blurs the line
well you're from New York you've seen
the way these these these homeless
people just kind of set up shop on a car
and they just stroll back and forth so
the sort of videos of uh of a homeless
guy walking through a uh Subway he's got
no shirt on no shoes so so pretty much
everyone's just kind of ignoring them
like you would in New York when you see
it nothing new and then he stops looks
at a woman with her food and then just
grabs it and just runs off and now now
no one knows it's a son but the guy
who's recording and the guy who is
running off with the food
but that's why it looks so real oh he
faked it yeah well that he did he fake
you
well what's what's a fake well that
would mean that everyone was in on it
yeah I don't think I think the only
person that wasn't on there was the guy
filming it and the guy who was but so so
is he really you know I know is he's
being an [ __ ] and filming it is a
better look at it but but what does that
do to our perception like the way I
shared I was just being funny like oh
man these homeless people aren't just
sitting around waiting for you to toss
some chains they're taking it out right
if I'm looking at that video I'm
thinking oh man
that is crazy that a God would do that
he must it must be real never mind the
fact that like someone just happened to
be filming somebody but it is kind of
funny and weird I've done that take
pictures of crazy [ __ ] I see your videos
and the guy just happens to run off and
with the food but it blurs this line
where everyone around you doesn't know
it's a joke you know it's a joke in the
and but the only part of it that makes
it a joke is that he's not actually a
homeless dude and it's set up for
entertainment it's kind of like um it's
like Candid Camera remember that like
like same idea I always think you
couldn't do some of these things that
they used to get away with you couldn't
do them today oh absolutely not there's
something some of those like prank shows
and stuff that they could actually get
away because they wouldn't get punched
in the face or whatever like society's
kind of gotten softer and people will
just be offended or whatever and then
there's some of those shows like uh uh
punked or whatever like now I think
people would just go to blows oh yeah
this is bad you know like there's a
heart in fact there's a whole video
series somebody's sent me or uh I guess
it's in New York but it but he's behind
bulletproof glass which is important
here
it says Chicago New York it's one of
those big big cities and the guys come
in and he goes and pays for stuff it's a
dude behind the counter as a dude and
the dude goes all right thanks Daddy you
have a good night and he said yo what
you call me he was like I just called
your daddy man what's up he was like
like what you mean that's where you
could call us just like dudes like this
like no I don't comment I don't play
that way and he just keeps and he goes
all right cool all right and I want a
nice one sugar lips
but because the guy can't get back on
the camera he's okay but but you're
right like if he could you know because
some of the dudes were like oh you lucky
you back behind that glass like the NBA
players they go they go up to the NBA
players and like the most recent one uh
they had um it was a kid that uh was in
uh Philadelphia and he got traded to the
Brooklyn Net Ben Simmons and I think
it's been Simmons and they went up to
him and they're like what's up what
Russell uh Russell Westbrook and they
like go up to the players and they
pretend that they don't know who they
are or like they think they're somebody
else and of course
and so they chased the dude out of a
store because he because they realized
immediately he was it's like now become
a thing where it's like you're trying to
disrespect me now it's like get out yeah
the the other thing uh that I think a
lot about is uh sometimes something
happens in life and you don't know if
it's like uh if they're trying to not
punk you but like you see stuff happen
and you're just like oh is that is that
real and you start kind of looking
around in today's society you're kind of
just like is there a camera somewhere is
there something happening or or whatever
and uh
I don't think that that's necessarily
the best thing you know over the long
run uh if everyone is always just
thinking about you know like how do you
capture footage like a life became uh
basically a TV set
that don't seem like a good path to go
down you know I'm in the Creator space
on on I guess the internet Twitter
social media YouTube and one of the
things I observed
and I I comment on the pretty regularly
much to the dismay of many of my fellow
creators but I go look man
uh I'm I'm 37 and I was putting together
my life
because of my age I was putting together
my life as if it wasn't gonna be no
cameras around you know I didn't I
didn't start boxing so I can make videos
of it for example I certainly didn't go
back to school so I could talk about it
on the internet and start to study
Physics like you know that's like it's
like hard things you do to form my life
that like look let's be real here I
could probably with what I understand
about internet make money now I could
probably never do anything worthwhile
again and just just make a living for
the rest of my life on the derivatives
on lessons from from that but I never
never do that because I don't think that
way
you see though especially with the guys
under 30 because it's a different
generation and that that sounds weird
but on the 30 would that make you you'd
be more 93 92. yeah so so yeah 92.
afterwards it means you you got to come
up and at the very least in your high
school days that's when social media is
going to start popping off
by the time you reach your 20s your
early 20s you're like why would I ever
go do something hard and challenging and
push myself
uh I'm going to instead I'm going to try
this internet thing I'm trying to make
this money thing so you get a whole
generation of guys
who have figured out how to make money
online
talking about and doing a lot of the
same things that everyone else was
because they all sound the same uh
slightly different flavor but I'll talk
about the same thing because there are
certain topics that are just more
engaging uh but if you don't have a life
to go behind like I can talk about it
and platitude when I see it because you
can look me I buy you know I went
through it right it's real life but but
if I can't you know if you you like some
kids from middle class suburb family you
start talking about you know discipline
habits and then you know pulling
yourself up and fixing it later it comes
off
you can get away with it in one platform
and another or whatever but but the
whole idea the whole point is that
you you only you really gain perspective
and live experience and then real
um these things start to mean something
when you have to use them you know it's
like like why would a kid join join the
Army now you know that's another
discussion right but why would we you
know go go and listen to the armed
services or take up a combat sport or or
thinking of things I've done arm service
think of a combat sport girl to learn a
very difficult uh subject pick up a
language or two very learning instrument
there are all these things but they take
time and they're hard and and the
failure is there and you're not gonna
face it and then on top of that it's not
good instant screen time it's not a good
investment right it's it's not you know
you can't capture it everyone wants to
be to be the man you know like I I
because I know a lot of guys personally
and I see some of the things they post
and I'm like man I know what you really
doing and making that's that's kind of
it's a little misleading I'm not going
to say because it ain't my thing you're
not you're not really selling money so I
make it but but I look gonna go that's
really misleading because they're
they're positioning themselves if they
make more than they actually do well
because yeah because you you can you
know one of the cool things is what I
like about travel and it's like this
about anything but travel is just the
first thing that comes to mind is that
if you don't know you assume it is a
very expensive thing to do it is hot you
know once you know you go
it's not really you know it is what it
is but but it's it's a good selling
point you're good at the internet you
can find how to get a lot of places in
the world but man if you're good at the
internet you can get a Lambo for two I
think have you heard about these guys
they're renting the Lambos they're
making it look like a life you can you
can really make
your life look a certain way but when I
when I sit down in front of you and I
talk and I realize you don't have any
type of skill you don't have any type of
experience you don't know or do anything
tied to a lot of marketer guys no con
like you know what the really I'm I'm
really big on the relationships in your
life I think
I'm not saying you gotta have a bunch
but I think one of the telltale signs of
somebody who is
who is
gone through a life is they have they
have long-term friends I don't like I'm
not interested in the guy who really
took that advice to her you know get rid
of your old friends when you level up
like no because there should be some
people in your life that they bring
something more to the table than
or are other than you know like advice
and ideas on how to hustle you know I
get like good solid relationships a lot
of these things right or all these
things to make a life we have we have
really become about and then I'm not
even gonna say we man because I'm not in
that generation I am very much a um damn
you're an elder Millennial at this point
um
we have or it has become really cool to
have the sizzle without the steak if
that you know to put it in in real easy
terms real easy let's look at the part
we don't really want to beat apart but I
don't think they're trying to do that
they don't even know what the part is to
be this is uh uh in business
specifically in the tech industry in
like the startup world uh I used to call
it a blog post founder
what I mean by that is like you could be
a Founder who went and read a bunch of
blog posts and you learned all the
things that you're supposed to say
and so to the untrained eye you could
trick a lot of people you could make
some money you could do this this
whatever but to the train die it takes
like two questions and it's just bad you
know and you can break it down
now the benefit and this is like kind of
a larger Story of All of society part of
the positive that story is that
information that used to be behind
closed doors into like good old boys
network all the stuff is now available
on the internet because there's somebody
who reads it who's a real entrepreneur
right and we'll go and implement it and
now they know how to work with their
board or then how to put together a
fundraising deck or there's a database
of investors to reach out to or you know
whatever
but with positive comes negatives and
there's a lot of people who now can kind
of fake it better because they read the
blog post and they think they know what
they're supposed to say whatever as
business and usually it's in an
environment where they're asking
somebody for money that's the same idea
yes is like okay cool now take it to uh
the successful people and one of the
things I tell all the young kids who uh
I see doing some of this stuff it's
always something I say man uh you you
ever seen a picture Elon Musk on his on
his uh jet
and by the way the picture you saw of
him on a yacht that's somebody else's
yacht and he didn't want the picture
taken
right one of the things that I really
proud myself on man uh
is is you know when you see because I
use IG like everyone else but I used to
promote my writing and really like
heavily but one but I do like to show
that I'm a real person and I exist so I
put pictures in my life and stuff but
it's always like uh you know it's me
with some friends with my girl or with
with the you know what's the last
picture or post that I was standing in
the water making a silly pose on the
beach man like just showing like but
because I think after a certain point
like when you you you learn the the
negatives that come with a lot of that
uh in fact I I would say like like I'm
really big on post and stuff that show
me living life
and actually living life you know we
weren't Budapest for one this is one of
the coolest things about the internet
I'm sure you like you can get this right
so so we were in uh we were in Budapest
for a week and then took a river cruise
down and then you uh stopped and
Bratislava Vienna lids and wanted to
play muting all right and and when we
were in Budapest she was there though
because of what my wife does she's
involved in travel and scheduling stuff
and and helping people take these
amazing trips places and so she was
there forever our River Cruise
conference so I I was like I'm gonna go
um but that week she was busy so what I
did I just let people know I was and
every day there was somebody else to
hang out and show me stuff and so I got
like real tours and real around just a
different View and I have an experience
and I took pictures with everybody
because I wanted to to show like this is
what what's really rich in my life being
able to like touch it out and have real
conversation with people people want to
talk to now still I'm not in Budapest
and so that's trained in the gym and
worked out that was hard because I'm not
training like a fighter anymore yeah but
it was but but that's the value and that
was like one of my favorite pictures of
posters all these people that I got to
meet and run into you don't you don't
see me you know sitting in a picture of
me in my first class or something like
that or or put the Lambos or posing with
mine
or mine my jewelry or my watch no it's
the people but but if I but if I don't
show but here's that's what they think
if I don't show that stuff people ain't
gonna buy for me or deal with me and I
get it there's like this whole image of
project but why would you wanna
I wonder what the motivation is to to do
it I guess it brings it back to a street
versus boardroom because there's there's
people who uh their entire life they're
trying to project the boardroom and then
when they get there I think a lot of
people realize like nah man you always
want to try to get back to uh the street
mentality to the uh uh this approach of
um
uh uh those people are trapped yeah
actually I'll tell you I'll tell you
another great filter I have my wife had
talked about a lot um
I don't think this will have any
identifying information I don't know the
person's name so uh that helps uh we're
in Austin Texas two years ago and it
kind of ended 2020. and
um we uh went out to eat
and uh we were somewhere else Sixth
Street or whatever kind of where if you
were a tourist this is where you would
go but uh it was kind of a nicer place
and uh guy walked in
um and you know I have a problem where I
pretty much only just wear t-shirts so
every once in a while you catch me maybe
in like a a black collar shirt that's a
big dress up for me but uh I was sitting
there and you know just regular clothes
or whatever my wife's same thing and
this guy walks in and he had a uh like a
button down like a dress shirt right
some jeans and nice shoes and he was
like ah you know cool
goes over in this outdoor patio and this
guy's a regular he knows every staff
person they call this stuff and people
are showing up and he's pointing he's
doing this he's Gordon drinks he's got
the whole thing going
and for whatever reason I just turned my
wife and I said I bet you a hundred
dollars that dudes uh medical device
salesman
right and she was like what do you mean
and I said
he's got just enough money
where he could ball in the local bar
but he ain't got a yacht a jet a Ferrari
like what you know whatever right and by
the way I always go back to like if he's
happy amazing congratulations you
[ __ ] crushed life
but I always ask myself like
did he one day say I'ma go and I'm gonna
become successful whatever the job
actually was right and uh I want to have
enough money to go to local bar and like
basically you know ball out yeah
probably not right and so like it was
less about this one individual as much
as it was just like there's a whole
lifestyle that I think people go and
they do and and they're almost like
fooling themselves a little bit but it
does go back to the fact of like if
they're truly happy you gotta just high
five and celebrate and like hey you
killed life
I think the reason why people always
point out these situations is because a
lot of people aren't actually happy and
and not only
of having happiness is is hard too
because there'll be there'll be moments
where you're good or almost you're not
whatever right but but ultimately
I I think
I don't I don't know why I don't like
the word happiness to describe it but
but I do wonder if fulfilled that's the
word yeah it's a great word uh fulfill
kind of purposeful because was like I
got a good friend and he described it
like this you know there's a lot because
of there's a lot of guys that figure out
how to make money and they figured it
out by by positioning themselves as
opposed to generating value and just
really getting in uh getting in the
right place for the Money Changes hands
and you you know kind of take a cut
however that looks whether it be an
affiliate cut or or a Founder's fear or
somebody whatever right he's just
getting the right place right palm or
moving somebody else's product and we
associate money with
we associate money with value but
personal value so it gets mixed up they
think have this and that and you there's
a lot of skeezy people money and there's
a lot of cool people who are broke and
it's not it's not this goes back to what
I was saying about you know why would
you drop your friends all right now you
drop somebody's a problem for various
reasons but uh if you cut out hanging
out with somebody it's because they're
happy doing something it might not be a
financially a lucrative move
but they're they're content they're
fulfilled they're still your solid homie
you guys still have are able to connect
it and and they're a good person right
but if it ain't about that that image
that money that you can project what are
you doing now and then that's what we're
oh we got a weird relationship with
money in this in this uh
Society we you know because I think I
think a lot about the stats 75 000. and
above to be happy they see you make 70 a
thousand dollars and any more other than
that doesn't have to happen is I think
yeah you know I think I think you know
we add inflation to that is probably
somewhere around 90 but like although
the point is there's there's a small
there's a place you reach where
everything after that is condo right is
it does it make you feel more fulfilled
and so you start going okay well well
how do I get there that's what makes a
difference and a lot of people just want
the money they don't consider that it's
path dependent you look because you can
go something dope okay you don't want to
be you don't want to do something
illegal
you know you could probably do do 18 to
20 hour shifts every other day uh doing
day work combine that with some some
Uber you get that money right you want
to know one of the number one jobs in
America make 100K I want to say driving
truck for Walmart yep oh it was a
starting pay 100K yep right if uh I
forget the stat maybe VP at Walmart a
million bucks a year
you ain't even got no one's gotta know
your name you ain't gotta have a
LinkedIn profile a million bucks a year
and you run some division or whatever
now again like it take time to get there
you gotta be smart you gotta know what
you're doing you know what I mean like
it's not like you just wake up one day
and go apply and Bam you're 22 years old
at Walmart but
100K as a truck driver and then look and
where exactly I actually made that
suggestion to a buddy of mine who was
trying to make the money I was like look
man if it's just about money it's gonna
be a truck driver like then now if you
want to like
if there are other things that are
important yeah but when you make it
about money
then you you miss out on I just I don't
see a lot of truck drivers posting on
Instagram saying six figures by 26.
right
but you got your truck drivers I know a
guy in the uh uh Boilermaker I mean he's
doing he's like 50 55 000 the 50 50 to
55 an hour depending on the job which
works out to be about 100K a year a
little a little less
um but like
there are so many ways to to get to this
this land of of Plenty and you know you
get there and you go all right well do I
like how I got there is is it all the
correct up to me what do I need you know
lifestyle creep is real M effort right
all of this you go and you you figure
out what matters to you and that's what
I think this all comes back to is that
people will have let
people have let let social media let
other people determine what's important
to them so they think I have to make
this life on this screen captured remove
almost all authenticity create a
somewhat uh fraudulent image or fraud
might be too strong for misleading is
probably better someone misleading image
to keep the money train going and it's
not that much money because well I don't
have much to show for my life outside of
this like if you've removed it I think
about this this imagination or not like
if there was a say tomorrow Parker is
shut down and we gotta start over from
scratch what am I going to do well I'm
I'm probably either going to work on
some mechanical or turn into a soldier
that's gonna be one of them be out there
forging hunting figuring things out and
defending the new the new settlement
with skill but but they have that skill
you know you you got to go do things and
and for figure these things out it's
kind of I'm kind of rambling but no it's
a it's a mentality yeah and I think
that's probably the biggest thing of uh
uh a lot of the people who maybe seem a
little lost or or that they're they're
trying to project an image of uh
somewhere where they're not yet I mean
that they can't get there or whatever uh
but but I do think a lot about could you
take that person drop them off somewhere
how long does it take to come back yeah
like I'm pregnant what's funny man was
just having this conversation
conversation with the wife I was like yo
you know I'm I'm really happy with the
the life I built and the connections and
everything like that because someone's
talking about it's not about who you
know I mean it's not about what you know
the the older I get and the more I learn
it really seems to be about you know you
know at least that helps a lot more than
what you know but I was like you know uh
I think about this like if I was wiped
out
tomorrow how long would it take to
recover I still have all my knowledge
and all my skills and I'm really happy
that that you know I'm not gonna like
immediately bounce back but it shouldn't
take more than a year than what I know
and how I know how to interact with
people and reach out with the Internet
or not and the skill I have
um I I think that's uh that says a
worthwhile kind of metric to stand it
like if you were wiped out like always
supposed to mean everything was on right
you just I was just regular old Atlanta
more and I showed up all I have are my
skills and my knowledge I don't even
have the cool boxing record I put
together I got you know
um how would I come back okay well I
know enough I'll do one thing or a few
things and it will make it
that that to me is uh true for very many
people in the sense of uh uh if they had
to start over from scratch they probably
would end up being further along over
the long run because they get well I
don't have to bump into as many walls
that's for sure a lot of walls man
that's the game just just figure it out
over and over over time you know one of
my favorite jobs I had in fact it was my
favorite one I did it longer than I had
to
I was a tutor for high school high
school is one of physics and Mathematics
I took on some English kid ones and I
was like never again I just
I mean and I like reading but I don't
like the way the school makes you read
and what you have to know and what the
work is but I can teach you how to gain
the right answer your thought process
through through physics chemistry or
math and and I think about that a lot
because now granted because the people
with that skill set there's not a it's
not a big overlap between who has enough
time to teach it and who knows enough
most people with us goes to have jobs
usually no so I was able to charge the
premium but but the impact I have is
that I still have
um many many of the kids I worked for
when they're they they're not adults now
they're in their 20 21 is uh they still
reach out I was in Chicago the other one
today and and you know she was telling
me about you know our dad was like you
know ask him about XYZ and stuff like
that and uh because because it was it
was
working in the world man it was a
physical it was Dad to be there and but
connect with humans that means a lot to
me it was my favorite second favorite
job most entertaining one after that
though uh definitely would have been
when I worked at the homeless shelter
you get a lot of stories man
[Laughter]
you just figure these things out and
have a good time I think there's a this
should almost be a component where you
gotta do some some uh some physical work
before you can talk about
Taco while doing stuff online yeah what
is uh that's very true where uh where
can we send people if they want to buy
the books or read any of your writing or
get more of these ideas because a lot of
people will hear this and they'll say
hey wait a minute this guy's got some
stuff figured out he's still pretty open
about figuring out more things in his
life uh and he's been able to become
self-sufficient on the internet which a
lot of folks I think are trying to
figure out so where can we send them to
to learn more from so I I am Ed
Lattimore everywhere on the internet at
lattimore.com is my website at Latimore
on Twitter at a lot of much my Instagram
at latter watch my Facebook and Linkedin
so yeah there's no more at Latimore's
you're the only one yeah you know what's
funny man I thought I I usually say when
people ask that I go look if somebody's
born after name at Lattimore I feel bad
for him I'm not gonna name my son that
man because Ed because if he ever wants
to go on the internet he's going to have
to to beat the SEO machine I've built
behind the net that's amazing a little
more so yeah that's how you find me man
I'm everywhere down to that name all
right Ed lattimore.com and then Ed
Lattimore and also on the social medias
yeah I really enjoyed today hey man I I
enjoyed it too it was a great great
conversation very
um I made some some insights that I did
not necessarily connect before now I
gotta dig deeper like like this is what
this is what I do like like when I have
an idea and it's a Flash and you know
let it be a flash for a minute and if I
keep thinking about I'm like okay I have
to like sit down that's why right or one
of the reasons why right because it
makes me smarter because if I get I
describe like right now that this
thought the link between uh the immune
system and reading right it's not really
connected at all but but now it's it's a
thought and I'm thinking about always
connects and they're like little
spinning uh magnetic poles and what I'll
do what I write is like running a magnet
over a piece of Steel and they all point
the same direction and now that piece is
still has Force like it's a Magdalene
can move things itself and that's how I
look at my thoughts when I when I write
is that I'm putting them all in a
the same direction writing is for Clear
thinking absolutely makes you better
writer one of my one of my favorite sins
you know I don't I don't write because
I'm smart I'm smart because I write
that's very very true that's a great
place to end my friend I appreciate very
much I hope everyone enjoyed this hey
thank you